foreign
welcome to the hearing of the Privacy
technology and the law subcommittee uh
thank my partner in this effort
Senator Hawley ranking member and I
particularly want to thank Senator
Durbin chairman of the Judiciary
Committee and he will be speaking
shortly this hearing is on the oversight
of our artificial intelligence the first
in a series of hearings intended to
write the rules
of AI our goal is to demystify and hold
accountable
those new technologies to avoid some of
the mistakes of the past
and now for some introductory remarks
too often
we have seen what happens when
technology outpaces regulation
the unbridled exploitation of personal
data the proliferation of disinformation
and the deepening of societal
inequalities
we have seen how algorithmic biases can
perpetuate discrimination and Prejudice
and how the lack of transparency can
undermine public Trust
this is not the future we want
if you were listening from home you
might have thought that voice was mine
and the words
from me but in fact that voice was not
mine
the words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software trained on my floor speeches
the remarks were written by chat gbt
when it was asked
how I would open this hearing
and you heard just now the result
I asked chat GPT
why did you pick those themes and that
content
and it answered and I'm quoting
Blumenthal has a strong record in
advocating for consumer protection and
civil rights he has been vocal about
issues such as data privacy
and
the potential for discrimination and
algorithmic decision making
therefore the statement emphasizes these
aspects
Mr Altman I appreciate chat gpt's
endorsement
uh in all seriousness this apparent
reasoning is pretty impressive
I am sure that we'll look back in a
decade and uh view chat GPT and gpt4
like we do the first cell phone those
big clunky things that we used to carry
around but we recognize that we are on
the verge really of a new era the audio
and my playing it may strike you as
curious or humorous but what
reverberated in my mind was what if I
had asked
it and what if it had
provided an endorsement of Ukraine
surrendering or Vladimir Putin's
leadership
that would have been really frightening
and the prospect is
more than a little scary to use the word
Mr Altman you have used yourself and I
think you have been very constructive in
calling attention to the pitfalls as
well as the promise and that's the
reason why we wanted you to be here
today and we thank you and our other
Witnesses for joining us for several
months now the public has been
fascinated with GPT
dally and other AI tools these examples
like the homework done by chat GPT or
the Articles and op-eds that it can
write feel like novelties
but the underlying advancement of this
era
are more than just research experiments
they are no longer fantasies of Science
Fiction they are real and present the
promises of
during cancer or developing new
understandings of physics and biology or
modeling climate and weather
all very encouraging and hopeful
but we also know the potential Harms
and we've seen them already weaponized
disinformation housing discrimination
harassment of women and impersonation
fraud voice cloning
deep fakes
these are the potential risks despite
the other rewards and for me
perhaps the biggest nightmare is the
looming new Industrial Revolution the
displacement of millions of workers the
loss of
huge numbers of jobs the need to prepare
for this new Industrial Revolution in
skill training
and relocation that may be required and
already industry leaders are calling
attention to
those challenges
to quote chat gbt
this is not
necessarily the future that we want
we need to maximize the good over the
bad
Congress has a choice now
we had the same Choice when we Face
social media we failed to seize that
moment the result is
Predators on the internet toxic content
exploiting children creating dangers for
them and Senator Blackburn and I and
others like Senator Durbin on the
Judiciary Committee are trying to deal
with it kids online safety act but
Congress failed to meet the moment on
social media now we have the obligation
to do it on AI before the threats and
the risks become real
sensible safeguards are not in
opposition to Innovation accountability
is not a burden far from it
they are the foundation of how we can
move ahead while protecting public trust
they are how we can lead the world in
technology and science but also in
promoting our Democratic Values
otherwise in the absence of that trust I
think
we may well lose both these are
sophisticated technology
but there are basic expectations common
in our law we can start with
transparency
AI companies ought to be required to
test their systems disclose known risks
and allow independent researcher access
we can establish scorecards and
nutrition labels
to encourage competition based on safety
and trustworthiness
limitations on use there are places
where the risk of AI is so extreme that
we ought to impose restriction or even
ban their use especially when it comes
to commercial invasions of privacy
for-profit and decisions that affect
people's livelihoods and of course
accountability or liability when AI
companies and their clients cause harm
they should be held liable
we should not repeat our past mistakes
for example section 230 forcing
companies to think ahead and be
responsible for the ramifications of
their business decisions can be the most
powerful tool of all
garbage in garbage out the principle
still applies
we ought to Beware of the garbage
whether it's going into
these platforms or coming out of them
and the ideas that we develop in this
hearing I think will provide a solid
path forward I look forward to
discussing them with you today and I
will just finish on this note the AI
industry doesn't have to wait for
Congress
I hope there are ideas and feedback from
this discussion and from the industry
and voluntary action such as we've seen
lacking
in many social media platforms and the
consequences have been huge
so I'm hoping that we will elevate
rather than have a race to the bottom
and I think these hearings will be an
important part of this conversation this
one is only the first
the ranking member and I have agreed
there should be more and we're going to
invite other industry leaders some have
committed to come experts academics
and the public we hope will participate
and with that I will turn to the ranking
member Senator Hawley
thank you very much Mr chairman thanks
to the witnesses for being here I
appreciate that several of you had long
Journeys to make in order to be here I
appreciate you making the time I look
forward to your testimony I want to
thank Senator Blumenthal for convening
this hearing for being a leader on this
topic you know a year ago we couldn't
have had this hearing because the
technology that we're talking about had
not burst into public Consciousness that
gives us a sense I think of just how
rapidly this technology that we're
talking about today is changing and
evolving and Transforming Our World
right before our very eyes I was talking
with someone just last night a
researcher in the field of Psychiatry
who was pointing out to me that the chat
GPT and generative AI these large
language models it's really like the
invention of the internet in scale at
least at least and potentially far far
more significant than that we could be
looking at one of the most significant
technological innovations in human
history
and I think my question is what kind of
an innovation is it going to be
is it going to be like the printing
press
that diffused knowledge and power and
learning widely across the landscape
that empowered ordinary everyday
individuals that led to Greater
flourishing that led above all to
Greater Liberty
or is it going to be more like the atom
bomb
huge technological breakthrough
but the consequences severe
terrible continue to haunt us to this
day
I don't know the answer to that question
I don't think any of us in the room know
the answer to that question because I
think the answer has not yet been
written and to in a certain extent it's
up to us here and to us as the American
people to write the answer
what kind of Technology will this be how
will we use it to better Our Lives how
will we use it to actually harness the
power of technological innovation for
the good of the American people for the
liberty of the American people not for
the power of the few
you know I was I was reminded of the
psychologist and writer Carl Young Who
said at the beginning of the last
century
that our ability for technological
innovation our capacity for
technological revolution had far
outpaced our ethical and moral ability
to apply and harness the technology we
developed that was a century ago I think
the story of the 20th century largely
bore him out
and I just wonder what will we say as we
look back at this moment
about these new technologies about
generative AI about these language
models and about the hosts of other AI
capacities that are even right now under
development not just in this country but
in China at the countries of our
adversaries and all around the world and
I think the question that young pose is
really the question that faces us will
we strike that balance between
technological innovation and our ethical
and moral responsibility
to humanity to Liberty
to the freedom of this country and I
hope that today's hearing will take us a
step closer to that answer thank you Mr
chairman thanks thanks Senator Hawley
I'm going to turn to the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee and the ranking
member Senator Graham if they have
opening remarks as well yes Mr chairman
thank you very much and Senator Hawley
as well uh last week in the this
committee full committee Senate
Judiciary Committee we dealt with an
issue that had been waiting for
attention for almost two decades and
that is what to do with the social media
when it comes to the abuse of children
we had four bills initially that were
considered by this committee and what
may be history in the making we passed
all four bills with unanimous roll calls
unanimous roll calls I can't remember
another time when we've done that and an
issue that important it's an indication
I think of the important position of
this Committee in the National debate on
issues that affect every single family
and affect our future in a profound way
1989 was a historic Watershed year in
America because that's when Seinfeld
arrived and we had a sitcom which was
supposedly about little or nothing which
turned out to be enduring I like to
watch it obviously and I'm always Marvel
when they show the phones that he used
in 1989 and I think about those in
comparison to what we carry around in
our pockets today it's a dramatic change
and I guess the question as I look at
that is does this change in phone
technology that we've witnessed through
the sitcom
really
exemplify a profound change in America
still unanswered but the very basic
question we face is whether or not
this the issue of AI is a quantitative
change in technology or qualitative
change
the suggestions that I've heard from
experts in the field suggest it's
qualitative
is an AI fundamentally different is it a
game changer is it so disruptive that we
need to treat it differently than other
forms of innovation that's the starting
point and the second starting point is
one that's humbling and that is effect
when you look at the record of Congress
and dealing with innovation technology
and Rapid change were not designed for
that
in fact the Senate was not created for
that purpose but just the opposite slow
things down take a harder look at it
don't react to public sentiment make
sure you're doing the right thing well
I've heard of the potential the positive
potential of AI and it is enormous you
can go through lists of the deployment
of technology that would say that an
idea you can sketch on a website for a
website on a napkin can generate
functioning code pharmaceutical
companies could use the technology to
identify new candidates to treat disease
the list goes on and on and then of
course the danger and it's profound as
well so I'm glad that this hearing is
taking place and I think it's important
for all of us to participate I'm glad
that it's a bipartisan approach we're
going to have to scramble to keep up
with the pace of innovation in terms of
our government public response to it but
this is a great start thank you Mr
chairman
thanks thanks Senator Irvin it is very
much a bipartisan approach very deeply
and broadly bipartisan and in that
Spirit I'm going to turn to
my friend Senator Graham
thank you that was not written by AI for
sure
uh let me introduce now the witnesses
we're very grateful to you for being
here uh Sam Altman is the co-founder and
CEO of open AI the AI research and
deployment company
behind chat GPT and Dally Mr Altman was
president of the early stage startup
accelerator why combinator from 1914 I'm
sorry 2014 to 2019 open AI was founded
in 2015. Christina Montgomery is IBM's
Vice President Chief privacy and Trust
officer overseeing the company's
Global privacy program policies
compliance and strategy she also chairs
IBM's AI ethics board a
multi-disciplinary team responsible for
the governance of AI and emerging
Technologies Christina has served in
various roles at IBM including corporate
secretary to the company's board of
directors she is a global leader in AI
ethics and governments and Ms Montgomery
also is a member of the United States
Chamber of Commerce AI commission and
the United States national AI advisory
committee which was established in 2022
to advise the president and the national
AI initiative office on a range of
topics related to AI Gary Marcus is a
leading voice in artificial intelligence
he's a scientist best-selling author and
entrepreneur founder of the robust Ai
and geometric AI acquired by Uber if I'm
not mistaken
and Emeritus professor of Psychology and
Neuroscience at NYU Mr Marcus is well
known for his challenges to contemporary
AI anticipating many of the current
limitations decades in advance and for
his research in human language
development and cognitive Neuroscience
thank you for being here and as you may
know our custom on the Judiciary
community is to swear in our Witnesses
before they testify so if you would all
please rise and raise your right hand
you solemnly swear that the testimony
that you you are going to give is the
truth the whole truth nothing but the
truth so help us out
thank you
Mr Altman we're going to begin with you
if that's okay
thank you thank you chairman Blumenthal
ranking member Holly members of the
Judiciary Committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today about
large neural networks it's it's really
an honor to be here even more so in the
moment than I expected my name is Sam
Altman I'm the Chief Executive Officer
of open AI
open AI was founded on the belief that
artificial intelligence has the
potential to improve nearly every aspect
of Our Lives
but also that it creates serious risks
we have to work together to manage
we're here because people love this
technology we think it can be a printing
press moment we have to work together to
make it so
open AI is an unusual company and we set
it up that way because AI is an unusual
technology
we are governed by a non-profit and our
activities are driven by our mission and
our Charter which commit us to working
to ensure that the broad distribution of
the benefits of AI and to maximizing the
safety of AI systems
we are working to build tools that one
day can help us make new discoveries and
address some of Humanity's biggest
challenges like climate change and
curing cancer
our current systems aren't yet capable
of doing these things
but it has been immensely gratifying to
watch many people around the world get
so much value from what these systems
can already do today
we love seeing people use our tools to
create to learn to be more productive
we're very optimistic that they're going
to be fantastic jobs in the future and
the current jobs can get much better
we also love seeing what developers are
doing to improve lives
for example
be my eyes used our new multimodal
technology in gpt4 to help visually
impaired individuals navigate their
environment
we believe that the benefits of the
tools we have deployed so far vastly
outweigh the risks but ensuring their
safety is vital to our work and we make
significant efforts to ensure that
safety is built into our systems at all
levels
before releasing any new system
openai conducts extensive testing
engages external experts for detailed
reviews and independent audits improves
the model's Behavior and implements
robust safety and monitoring systems
before we release gpt4 our latest model
we spent over six months conducting
extensive evaluations external red
teaming and dangerous capability testing
we are proud of the progress that we
made
gpt4 is more likely to respond helpfully
and truthfully
and refuse harmful requests than any
other widely deployed model of similar
capability
however
we think that regulatory intervention by
governments will be critical to mitigate
the risks of increasingly powerful
models
for example the US government might
consider a combination of Licensing and
testing requirements for development and
release of AI models above a threshold
of capabilities
there are several other areas I
mentioned in my written testimony where
I believe that companies like ours can
partner with governments
including ensuring that the most
powerful AI models adhere to a set of
safety requirements
facilitating processes to develop and
update safety measures and examining
opportunities for Global coordination
and as you mentioned uh I think it's
important that companies have their own
responsibility here no matter what
Congress does
this is a remarkable time to be working
on artificial intelligence
but as this technology advances we
understand that people are anxious about
how it could change the way we live we
are too
but we believe that we can and must work
together to identify and manage the
potential downsides so that we can all
enjoy the tremendous upsides
it is a scent that powerful AI is
developed with democratic values in mind
and this means that U.S leadership is
critical
I believe that we will be able to
mitigate the risks in front of us and
really capitalize on this Technology's
potential to grow the US economy and the
worlds and I look forward to working
with you all to meet this moment and I
look forward to answering your questions
thank you
thank you thank you Mr Altman Ms
Montgomery
chairman Blumenthal ranking member Holly
and members of the subcommittee
thank you for today's opportunity to
present
AI is not new but it's certainly having
a moment
recent breakthroughs in generative Ai
and the Technologies dramatic surge in
the public attention has rightfully
raised serious questions at the heart of
today's hearing
what are ai's potential impacts on
society
what do we do about bias what about
misinformation misuse or harmful content
generated by AI systems
Senators these are the right questions
and I applaud you for convening today's
hearing to address them head on
well AI may be having its moment the
moment for government to play a role has
not passed us by
this period of focused public attention
onai is precisely the time to Define and
build the right guard rails to protect
people and their interests
at its core AI is just a tool and tools
can serve different purposes
to that end IBM urges Congress to adopt
a Precision regulation approach to AI
this means establishing rules to govern
the deployment of AI in specific use
cases not regulating the technology
itself
such an approach would involve four
things
first different rules for different
risks
the strongest regulation should be
applied to use cases with the greatest
risks to people and Society
second clearly defining risks there must
be clear guidance on AI uses or
categories of AI supported activity that
are inherently high risk
this common definition is key to
enabling a clear understanding of what
regulatory requirements will apply in
different use cases and contexts
third be transparent so AI shouldn't be
hidden consumers should know when
they're interacting with an AI system
and that they have recourse to engage
with a real person should they so desire
no person anywhere should be tricked
into interacting with an AI system
and finally showing the impact for
higher risk use cases companies should
be required to conduct impact
assessments that show how their systems
perform against tests for bias and other
ways that they could potentially impact
the public and to a test that they've
done so
by following risk-based use
case-specific Approach at the core of
precision regulation Congress can
mitigate the potential risks of AI
without hindering innovation
but businesses also play a critical role
in ensuring the responsible deployment
of AI
companies active in developing or using
AI must have strong internal governance
including among other things designating
a lead AI ethics official responsible
for an organization's trustworthy AI
strategy
standing up an Ethics board or a similar
function as a centralized Clearinghouse
for research resources to help guide
implementation of that strategy
IBM has taken both of these steps and we
continue calling on our industry peers
to follow suit
our aifx board plays a critical role in
overseeing internal AI governance
processes creating reasonable guard
rails to ensure we introduce technology
into the world and a responsible and
safe manner
it provides centralized governance and
accountability while still being
flexible enough to support decentralized
initiatives across IBM's Global
operations
we do this because we recognize that
Society grants our license to operate
and with AI the stakes are simply too
high we must build not undermine the
public Trust
the era of AI cannot be another era of
move fast and break things
but we don't have to slam the brakes on
Innovation either these systems are
within our control today as are the
solutions
what we need at this pivotal moment is
clear reasonable policy and sound guard
rails these guardrails should be matched
with meaningful steps by the business
Community to do their part
Congress and the business Community must
work together to get this right the
American people deserve no less
thank you for your time and I look
forward to your questions thank you
Professor Marcus
today
thank you Senators today's meeting is
historic I'm profoundly grateful to be
here I come as a scientist someone who's
founded AI companies and is someone who
genuinely loves AI but who is
increasingly worried there are benefits
but we don't yet know whether they will
outweigh the risks
fundamentally these new systems are
going to be destabilizing they can and
will create persuasive lies at a scale
Humanity has never seen before Outsiders
will use them to affect our elections
insiders to manipulate our markets and
our political systems democracy itself
is threatened
chatbots will also clandestinely shape
our opinions potentially exceeding what
social media can do choices about data
sets that AI companies use will have
enormous unseen influence those who
choose the data will make the rules
shaping Society in subtle but powerful
ways
there are other risks too many stemming
from the in from the inherent
unreliability of current systems a law
professor for example was accused by a
chatbot of sexual harassment untrue and
it pointed to a Washington Post article
that didn't even exist
the more that that happens the more that
anybody can deny anything as one
prominent lawyer told me on Friday
defendants are starting to claim that
plaintiffs are making up legitimate
evidence these sorts of allegations
undermine the abilities of juries to
decide what or who to believe and
contribute to the undermining of
democracy
poor medical advice could have serious
consequences too an open source large
language model recently seems to have
played a role in a person's decision to
take their own life the large language
model asked the human if you wanted to
die why didn't you do it earlier and
Then followed up with were you thinking
of me when you overdosed without ever
referring the patient to the human
health that was obviously needed another
system rushed out and made available to
millions of children told a person
posing as a 13 year old how to lie to
her parents about a trip with a 31 year
old man
further threats continue to emerge
regularly a month after gpt4 was
released openai released chat GPT
plugins which quickly LED others to
develop something called Auto GPT with
direct access to the internet the
ability to write source code and
increased powers of automation this may
well have drastic and difficult to
predict security consequences what
criminals are going to do here is to
create counterfeit people it's hard to
even Envision the consequences of that
we have built machines that are like
Bulls in a china shop powerful Reckless
and difficult to control
we all more or less agree on the values
we would like for our AI systems to
honor we want for example for our
systems to be transparent to protect our
privacy to be free of bias and above all
else to be safe but current systems are
not in line with these values current
systems are not transparent they do not
adequately protect our privacy and they
continue to perpetuate bias and even
their makers don't entirely understand
how they work most of all we cannot
remotely guarantee that they're safe and
hope here is not enough
the big tech companies preferred plan
boils down to trust us but why should we
the sums of money at stake are
mind-boggling emissions drift open ai's
original mission statement proclaimed
our goal is to advance Ai and the way
that most is most likely to benefit
Humanity as a whole unconstrained by a
need to generate Financial return seven
years later they're largely beholden to
Microsoft embroiled in part in epic
battle of search engines that routinely
make things up and that's forced
alphabet to rush out products and
de-emphasize safety Humanity has taken a
back seat
AI is moving incredibly fast with lots
of potential but also lots of risks we
obviously need government involved and
we need the tech companies involved both
big and small but we also need
independent scientists not just so that
we scientists can have a voice but so
that we can participate directly in
addressing the problems and evaluating
Solutions and not just after products
are released but before and I'm glad
that Sam mentioned that we need tight
collaboration between independent
scientists and governments in order to
hold the company's feet to the fire
allowing independent access to the
assist independent Sciences allowing
independent scientists access to these
systems before they are widely released
as part of a clinical trial like safety
evaluation is a vital First Step
ultimately we may need something like
CERN Global International and neutral
but focused on AI safety rather than
high energy physics we have
unprecedented opportunities here but we
are also facing a perfect storm of
corporate irresponsibility widespread
deployment lack of adequate regulation
and inherent unreliability
AI is among the most world-changing
Technologies ever already changing
things more rapidly than almost any
technology in history we acted too
slowly with social media many
unfortunate decisions got locked in with
lasting Consequence the choices we make
now will have lasting effects for
decades maybe even centuries the very
fact that we are here today in
bipartisan fashion to discuss these
matters gives me some hope thank you Mr
chairman thanks very much Professor
Marcus we're going to have seven minute
rounds of questioning and I will begin
first of all Professor Marcus we are
here today because we do face that
perfect storm some of us might
characterize it more like a bomb in a
china shop not a bull and as Senator
Hawley indicated there are precedence
here not only the Atomic Warfare era but
also the Genome Project the research on
genetics where there was International
cooperation as a result and we want to
avoid those past mistakes as I indicated
in my opening statement that we're
committed on social media that is
precisely the reason we are here today
chat GPT
makes mistakes all AI does and it can be
a convincing liar
what people call hallucinations
that might be an innocent problem in the
opening of a Judiciary subcommittee
hearing where a voice is impersonated
mine in this instance
or quotes from research papers that
don't exist but chat GPT and Bard are
willing to answer questions about life
or death matters for example drug
interactions
and those kinds of mistakes can be
deeply damaging I'm interested in how we
can have reliable information about the
accuracy and trustworthiness of these
models and how we can create competition
and consumer disclosures that reward
greater accuracy
the National Institutes of standards and
Technology actually already has an AI
accuracy test the face recognition
vendor test
it doesn't solve for all the issues with
facial recognition but the scorecard
does provide useful information about
the capabilities and flaws of these
systems so there's work on models to
assure accuracy and integrity my
question uh let me begin with you Mr
Altman is uh should we consider
independent testing labs
to provide scorecards and nutrition
labels or the equivalent of nutrition
labels packaging that indicates to
people whether or not
the content can be trusted what the
ingredients are and what the garbage
going in may be because it could result
in garbage going out
yeah I I think that's a great idea I
think that companies should put their
own sort of you know hear the results of
our test of our model before we release
it here's here's where it has weaknesses
here's where it has strengths but also
independent audits for that are very
important
these models are getting more accurate
over time uh you know this is this is as
we have I think said as loudly as anyone
this technology is in its early stages
it definitely still makes mistakes we
find that people that users are pretty
sophisticated and understand where the
mistakes are that they need or likely to
be that they need to be responsible for
verifying what the models say that they
go off and check it
um
I I worry that as the models get better
and better uh the users can have sort of
less and less of Their Own
discriminating thought process around it
but but I think users are more capable
than we could often give them credit for
in in conversations like this I think a
lot of disclosures which if you've used
chat gbt you'll see about the
inaccuracies of the model are also
important and I'm I'm excited for a
world where companies publish with the
models information about how they behave
where the inaccuracies are and
independent agencies or companies
provide that as well I think it's a
great idea I alluded in my opening
remarks to the the jobs issue the
economic effects on employment uh I
think you have
said uh in fact and I'm going to quote
development of superhuman machine
intelligence is probably the greatest
threat to the continued existence of
humanity end quote you may have had in
mind the effect on on jobs which is
really my biggest nightmare
in the long term let me ask you uh what
your biggest nightmare is and whether
you share that concern
like with all technological revolutions
I expect there to be significant impact
on jobs but exactly what that impact
looks like is very difficult to predict
if we went back to the the other side of
a previous technological Revolution
talking about the jobs that exist on the
other side
um you know you can go back and read
books of this it's what people said at
the time it's difficult
I believe that there will be far greater
jobs on the other side of this and the
jobs of today will get better I think
it's important
first of all I think it's important to
understand and think about gpt4 as a
tool not a creature which is easy to get
confused and it's a tool that people
have a great deal of control over in how
they use it and second gpt4 and things
other systems like it are good at doing
tasks not jobs and so you see already
people that are using gpt4 to do their
job much more efficiently by helping
them with tasks now gbt4 will
I think entirely automate away some jobs
and it will create new ones that we
believe will be much better this happens
again my understanding of the history of
technology is one long technological
Revolution not a bunch of different ones
put together but this has been
continually happening we as our quality
of life raises and as machines and tools
that we create can help us live better
lives uh the bar raises for what we do
and and our human ability and what we
spend our time going after uh goes after
more ambitious more satisfying projects
so there there will be an impact on jobs
uh we try to be very clear about that
and I think it will require
partnership between the industry and
government but mostly action by
government to figure out how we want to
mitigate that
um
but I'm very optimistic about how great
the jobs of the future will be thank you
let me ask Ms Montgomery and Professor
Marcus for your reactions those
questions as well is Montgomery on the
jobs Point yeah I mean well it's a
hugely important question and it's one
that we've been talking about for a
really long time at IBM you know we do
believe that Ai and we've said it for a
long time is going to change every job
new jobs will be created many more jobs
will be transformed and some jobs will
transition away I'm a personal example
of a job that didn't exist when I joined
IBM and I have a team of AI governance
professionals who are in new roles that
we created you know as early as three
years ago I mean they're new and they're
growing so I think the most important
thing that we could be doing and can and
should be doing now is to prepare the
workforce of today and the workforce of
tomorrow for partnering with AI
Technologies and using them and we've
been very involved for for years now in
doing that in focusing on skills-based
hiring
in educating for the skills of the
future our skills build platform has
seven million Learners and over a
thousand courses worldwide focused on
skills and we've pledged to train 30
million individuals by 2030 in the
skills that are needed for society today
thank you Professor Marcus man go back
to the first question as well absolutely
on on the subject of nutrition labels I
I think we absolutely need to do that I
think that there's some technical
challenges in that building proper
nutrition labels goes hand in hand with
transparency the biggest scientific
challenge in understanding these models
is how they generalize what do they
memorize and what new things do they do
the more that there's in the data set
for example the thing that you want to
test accuracy on the less you can get a
proper read on that so it's important
first of all that scientists be part of
that process and second that we have
much greater transparency about what
actually goes into these systems if we
don't know what's in them then we don't
know exactly how well they're doing when
we give something new and we don't know
how good a benchmark that will be for
something that's entirely novel so I
could go into that more but I want to
flag that
second is on jobs past performance
history is not a guarantee of the future
it has always been the case in the past
that we have had more jobs that new jobs
new professions come in as new
technologies come in I think this one's
going to be different and the real
question is over what time time scale is
it going to be 10 years is it going to
be 100 years and I don't think anybody
knows the answer to that question I
think in the long run so-called
artificial general intelligence really
will replace a large fraction of human
jobs we're not that close to artificial
general intelligence despite all of the
media hype and so forth I would say that
what we have right now is just small
sampling of the AI that we will build 20
years people will laugh at this as I
think it was Senator Hawley made the but
maybe Senator Durbin made the example
about this it was Senator Durbin made
the example about cell phones when we
look back at the AI of today 20 years
ago we'll be like wow that stuff was
really unreliable it couldn't really do
planning which is an important technical
aspect it's reasoning wasability and
reasoning abilities were limited but
when we get to AGI artificial general
intelligence mainly let's say it's 50
years that really is going to have I
think profound effects on labor and
there's just no way around that and last
I don't know if I'm allowed to do this
but I will note that Sam's worst fear I
do not think is employment he never told
us what his worst fear actually is and I
think it's germane to find out
thank you I'm going to ask
Mr Altman if he cares to respond
look we have tried to be very clear
about the magnitude of the risks here I
I think jobs and employment and what
we're all going to do with our time
really matters I agree that when we get
to very powerful systems the landscape
will change I think I'm just more
optimistic that we are incredibly
creative and we find new things to do
with better tools and that will keep
happening
um
my worst fears are that we cause
significant we the field the technology
the industry cause significant harm to
the world uh I think that could happen a
lot of different ways it's why we
started the company it's a big part of
why I'm here today and why we've been
here in the past and we've been able to
spend some time with you I think if this
technology goes wrong it can go quite
wrong and we want to be vocal about that
we want to work with the government to
prevent that from happening but we we
try to be very clear-eyed about what the
downside case is and the work that we
have to do to mitigate that
thank you and and our hope is that the
rest of the industry will follow the
example that you and
IBM Ms Montgomery have set by coming
today
and meeting with us as you have done
privately in helping to guide what we're
going to do so that we can Target the
harms and avoid unintended consequences
to the good
thanks
Senator Hawley
thank you again Mr chairman thanks to
the witnesses for being here Mr Altman I
think you grew up in St Louis if I did
not mistaken it's great to see it is a
great place Missouri in here it is thank
you I want to I want that noted
especially underlined in the record
Missouri is a great place that is the
takeaway from today's hearing maybe we
just stop there Mr chairman
um let me ask you Mr Altman I think I'll
start with you and I'll just preface by
saying my questions here are an attempt
to get my head around and to ask all of
you to help us to get our heads around
what these this generative AI
particularly the large language models
what it can do so I'm trying to
understand its capacities and then its
significance so I'm looking at a paper
here entitled large language models
trained on media diets can predict
public opinion this is just posted about
a month ago the authors are two Andreas
and Roy and their conclusion of this
work was done at MIT and then also at
Google the conclusion is that large
language models can indeed predict
public opinion and they go through and
and model why this is the case and they
they conclude ultimately that an AI
system can predict human survey
responses by adapting a pre-trained
language model to subpopulation specific
media diets in other words you can feed
the model a particular set of of media
inputs and it can with remarkable
accuracy in the paper goes into this
predict then what people's opinions will
be I I'm I want to think about this in
the context of Elections
if these large language models can even
now based on the information we put into
them quite accurately predict public
opinion
you know ahead of time I mean predict
it's before you even ask the public
these questions
what will happen when entities whether
it's corporate entities or whether it's
governmental entities or whether it's
campaigns or whether it's foreign actors
take this survey information these
predictions about public opinion and
then fine-tune strategies to elicit
certain responses certain behavioral
responses I mean we already know this
committee has her testimony I think
three years ago now about the effect of
something as prosaic it now seems as
Google search
the effect that this has on voters in an
election particularly undecided voters
in the final days of an election who may
try to get information from Google
search and what an enormous effect the
ranking of the Google search the
articles that it returns has come an
enormous effect on an undecided voter
this of course is orders of magnitude
far more powerful far more significant a
far more directive if you like so Mr
Altman maybe you can
help me understand here what some of the
significance of this is should we be
concerned about models that can large
language models that can predict
survey opinion and then can help
organizations entities fine-tune
strategies to illicit behaviors from
voters should we be worried about this
for our elections yeah uh thank you
Senator Hawley for the question it's one
of my areas of greatest concern the the
the more General ability of these models
to manipulate to persuade and to provide
sort of one-on-one uh you know
interactive disinformation I think
that's like a broader version of what
you're talking about but given that
we're going to face an election next
year and these models are getting better
I think this is a significant area of
concern I think there's a lot there's a
lot of policies that companies can
voluntarily adopt and I'm happy to talk
about what we do there
I do think some regulation would be
quite wise on this topic uh
someone mentioned earlier it's something
we really agree with people need to know
if they're talking to an AI if content
that they're looking at might be
generated or might not I think it's a
great thing to do is to make that clear
I think we also will need rules
guidelines about what
what's expected in terms of disclosure
from a company providing a model that
could have
these sorts of abilities that you talk
about so I'm nervous about it
I think people are able to adapt quite
quickly when Photoshop came onto the
scene a long time ago you know for a
while people were really quite fooled by
photoshopped images and then pretty
quickly developed an understanding that
images might be photoshopped this will
be like that but on steroids and the the
interactivity the ability to really
model predict humans well as you talked
about I think is going to require
a combination of companies doing the
right thing regulation and public
education do you Mr Professor Marcus do
you want to address those yeah I'd like
to add two things one is in the appendix
to my remarks I have two papers to make
you even more concerned
um one is in the Wall Street Journal
just a couple days ago called help my
political beliefs were altered by a chat
bot and I think the scenario you raised
was that we might basically observe
people and use surveys to figure out
what they're saying but as Sam just
acknowledged the risk is actually worse
that the systems will directly maybe not
even intentionally manipulate people and
that was the thrust of the Wall Street
Journal article and it links to an
article that I've also linked to called
interacting and it's not yet published
not yet peer-reviewed interacting with
opinionated language models changes
users views and this comes back
ultimately to data one of the things
that I'm most concerned about with gpt4
is that we don't know what it's trained
on I guess Sam knows but the rest of us
do not and what it is trained on has
consequence Sciences for essentially the
biases of the system we could talk about
that in technical terms but how these
systems might lead people about depends
very heavily on what data is trained on
them and so we need transparency about
that and we probably need scientists in
there doing analysis in order to
understand what the political influences
of for example of these systems might be
and it's not just about politics it can
be about health it could be about
anything these systems absorb a lot of
data and then what they say reflects
that data and they're going to do it
differently depending on what what's in
that data so it makes a difference if
they're trained on the Wall Street
Journal as opposed to the New York Times
or or Reddit I mean actually they're
largely trained on all of this stuff but
we don't really understand the
composition of that and so we have this
issue of potential manipulation and it's
even more complex than that because it's
subtle manipulation people may not be
aware of what's going on that was the
point of both the Wall Street Journal
article and the other article that I
called your attention to let me ask you
about
AI systems trained on personal data the
kind of data that for instance the
social media companies the major
platforms Google meta Etc collect on all
of us routinely we've had many a chat
about this in this committee over many a
year now but the massive amounts of data
personal data that the companies have on
each one of us
an AI system that is that is trained on
that individual data that knows each of
us better than ourselves and also knows
the billions of data points about human
behavior human language interaction
generally wouldn't we be able wouldn't
we can't we foresee an AI system that is
extraordinarily good at determining what
will grab human attention and what will
keep an individual's attention and so
for the war for attention the war for uh
clicks that is currently going on on all
of these platforms is how they make
their money I'm just imagining a an AI
system these these AI models
supercharging that war for attention
such that we now have technology that
will allow individual targeting of a
kind we have never even imagined before
where the AI will know exactly what Sam
Altman finds uh attention grabbing will
know exactly what Josh Hawley finds
attention grabbing will be able to
elicit to grab our attention and then
elicit responses from us in a way that
we have heretofore not even been able to
imagine should we be concerned about
that for its corporate applications for
the monetary applications for the
manipulation that that could come from
that Mr almond
uh yes we should be concerned about that
to be clear uh openai does not we're not
off you know we wouldn't have an ad
based business model so we're not trying
to build up these profiles of our users
we're not we're not trying to get them
to use it more actually we'd love it if
they use it less because we don't have
enough gpus
um but I think other companies are
already and certainly will in the future
use AI models to create
you know very good ad predictions of
what a user will like I think it's
already happening in many ways Miss
Marcus anything you want to add hyperton
yes um and perhaps Ms Montgomery will
want to too as well I don't but um hyper
targeting of advertising is definitely
going to come I agree that that's not
been open ai's business model
um of course now they're working for
Microsoft and I don't know what's in
Microsoft's thoughts
um but we will definitely see it maybe
it will be with open source language
models I don't know but the technology
there is let's say part way there to
being able to do that and we'll
certainly get there
so we're an Enterprise technology
company not consumer Focus so the space
isn't one that we necessarily operate in
in terms of but these issues are hugely
important issues and it's why we've been
out ahead in developing the technology
that will help to ensure that you can do
things like produce a fact sheet that
has the ingredients of what your data is
trained on data sheets model cards all
those types of things and calling for as
I've mentioned today transparency so you
know what the algorithm was trained on
and then you also know and can manage
and monitor continuously over the life
cycle of an AI model the behavior and
the performance of that model
Senator Durbin
thank you I think what's happening today
in this hearing room is historic
I can't recall when we've had people
representing
large corporations or private sector
entities come before us and plead with
us to regulate them
in fact many people in the Senate have
base their careers on the opposite
that the economy will Thrive if
Government gets the hell out of the way
and what I'm hearing instead today is
that stop me before I innovate again
uh message and I'm just curious as to
how we're going to achieve this
as I mentioned section 230 in my opening
remarks
we learned something there
we decided that in section 230 that we
were basically going to absolve the
industry from liability
for a period of time as it came into
being
well
Mr Oldman on the podcast earlier this
year you agreed with host Kara Swisher
that section 230 doesn't apply to
generative AI
and that developers like open AI should
not be entitled to full immunity for
harms caused by their products
so what have we learned from 230 that
applies to your situation with AI
thank you for the question Senator I I
don't know yet exactly what the right
answer here is I'd love to collaborate
with you to figure it out I do think for
a very new technology we need a new
framework
certainly companies like ours bear a lot
of responsibility for the tools that we
put out in the world but tool users do
as well and how we want and also people
that will build on top of it between
them and the end consumer and how we
want to come up with a live a liability
framework there
is a super important question
um and we'd love to work together
the point I want to make is this when it
came to online platforms the inclination
of the government was get out of the way
this is a new industry don't over
regulate it in fact give them some
breathing space and see what happens I'm
not sure I'm happy with the outcome as I
look at online platforms me either and
the harms that they've created
problems that we've seen demonstrated in
this committee child exploitation cyber
bullying online drug sales and more
I don't want to repeat that mistake
again and what I hear is the opposite
suggestion from the private sector and
that is come in the front end of this
thing and establish some liability
standards Precision regulation
for a major company like IBM to come
before this committee and say to the
government please regulate us
can you explain the difference in
thinking from the past and now
yeah absolutely
um so for us this comes back to the
issue of trust and Trust in the
technology trust is our license to
operate as I mentioned in my remarks
um and so we firmly believe and we've
been calling for precision regulation of
artificial intelligence for years now
this is not a new position we think that
technology needs to be deployed in a
risk responsible and clear way that
people we've taken principles around
that trust and transparency we call them
our principles that were articulated
years ago and build them into practices
that's why we're here advocating for
precision regulatory approach so we
think that AI should be regulated at the
point of risk essentially and that's the
point at which technology meets Society
let's take a look at what that might
appear to be
members of Congress are pretty smart a
lot of people maybe not as smart as we
think we are many times and government
certainly has a capacity to do amazing
things
but when you talk about our ability to
respond to the current Challenge and
perceive challenge of the future
challenges which you all have described
in terms which are hard to
forget
as you said Mr Altman things can go
quite wrong she said Mr Marcus democracy
is threatened I mean
the magnitude of the challenge you're
giving us is substantial I'm not sure
that we respond quickly and with enough
expertise to deal with it
Professor Marcus you made a reference to
CERN
the international Arbiter of nuclear
research I suppose I don't know if
that's a fair characterization but it's
a characterization I'll start with
what is it what agency of this
government do you think exists that
could respond to the challenge that
you've laid down today
we have many agencies that can respond
in some ways for example the FTC
um we have CC and there are many
agencies that can but my view is that we
probably need a cabinet level uh
organization within the United States in
order to address this and my reasoning
for that is that the number of risks is
large the amount of information to keep
up on is so much I think we need a lot
of technical expertise I think we need a
lot of coordination of these efforts so
there is one model here where we stick
to only existing law and try to shape
all of what we need to do and each
agency does their own thing but I think
that AI is going to be such a large part
of our future and is so complicated and
moving so fast this does not fully solve
your problem about a dynamic world but
it's a step in that direction to have an
agency that's full-time job is to do
this I personally have suggested in fact
that we should want to do this at a
global way I wrote an article in The
Economist I have a link in here an
invited essay for the economist
suggesting we might want an
international Agency for AI That's what
I wanted to go to next and that is the
fact that I'll get it aside from the
CERN and nuclear examples because
government was involved in that from day
one at least in the United States but
now we're dealing with Innovation which
doesn't necessarily have a boundary that
we may create a great U.S agency and I
hope that we do that may have
jurisdiction over U.S corporations and
U.S activity but doesn't have a thing to
do with what's going to bombard us from
outside the United States how do you
give this International Authority
the authority to regulate in a fair way
for all entities involved in AI I think
that's probably over my pay grade I
would like to see it happen and I think
it may be inevitable that we push there
I mean I think the politics behind it
are obviously complicated I'm really
heartened by the degree to which this
room is bipartisan and supporting the
same things and that makes me feel like
it might be possible I would like to see
the United States take leadership in
such organization it has to involve the
whole world and not just the US to work
properly I think even from the
perspective of the companies it would be
a good thing so the companies themselves
do not want a situation where you take
these models which are expensive to
train and you have to have 190 some of
them
um you know one for every country that
that wouldn't be a good way of operating
when you think about the energy costs
alone just for training these systems it
would not be a good model if every
country has its own policies and each
for each jurisdiction every company has
to train another model maybe you know
different states are different so
Missouri and California have different
rules and so then that requires even
more training of these expensive models
with huge climate impact
um and I mean just it would be very
difficult for the companies to operate
if there was no Global coordination and
so I think that we might get the
companies on board if there's bipartisan
support here and I think there's support
around the world that is entirely
possible that we could develop such a
thing but obviously there are many you
know nuances here of diplomacy that are
over my pay grade I I would love to
learn from you all to try to help make
that happen Mr Altman can I weigh in
just briefly briefly please uh I want to
Echo support for what Mr Marcus said I
think the U.S should lead here and do
things first but to be effective
we do need something Global as you
mentioned this can this can happen
everywhere there is precedent I know it
sounds naive to call for something like
this and it sounds really hard there is
precedent we've done it before with the
iaea we've talked about doing it for
other Technologies
they're given what it takes to make
these models the chip supply chain the
sort of limited number of competitive
gpus the power the US has over these
companies I think there are paths to
the U.S setting some International
standards that other countries would
need to collaborate with and be part of
that are actually workable even though
it sounds on its face like a impractical
idea and I think it would be great for
the world thank you Mr chairman thank
you thanks Senator Durbin and in fact I
think we're going to hear more about
what Europe is doing European Parliament
already is acting on an AI act uh on
social media Europe is ahead of us uh we
need to be in the lead I think
your your point is very well taken let
me turn to Senator Graham
Senator Blackburn thank you Mr chairman
and thank you all for being here with us
today I put into my chat GPT account
should Congress regulate AI chat GPT and
it gave me four Pros four cons and says
ultimately the decision rests with
Congress and deserves careful
consideration so on that you know it was
uh very balanced I recently visited with
the Nashville Technology Council I
represent Tennessee and of course you
had people there from Health Care
Financial Services Logistics educational
entities and they're concerned about
what they see happening with AI with the
utilizations for their companies Miss
Montgomery you know some similar to you
they've got Health Care people are
looking at disease analytics they're
looking at predictive diagnosis how this
can better
the outcomes for patients la Logistics
industry looking at ways to save time
and money and yield efficiencies
you've got financial services that are
saying how does this work with Quantum
how does it work with blockchain how can
we use this but uh it I think as we have
talked with them Mr chairman one of the
things that continues to come up is yes
Professor Marcus as you were saying the
EU different entities are ahead of us in
this but we have never established a
federally preem given preemption for
online privacy for data security and put
some of those foundational elements in
place which is something that we need to
do as we look at this and it will
require that Commerce Committee
Judiciary Committee decide how we move
forward so that people own their virtual
you and um
Mr Altman I was glad to see last week
that your open AI models are not going
to be trained using consumer data I
think that that is important and if we
have a second round I've got a host of
questions for you on data security and
privacy
but I think it's important to let people
control their virtual you their
information in these settings and I want
to come to you on music and content
creation because we've got a lot of
songwriters and artists and a I think we
have the best creative community on the
face of the Earth they're in Tennessee
and they should be able to decide if
they're copyrighted songs and images are
going to be used to train these models
and I'm concerned about open ai's
jukebox
it offers some re-renditions in the
style of Garth Brooks which suggests
that open AI is trained on Garth Brooks
songs I went in this weekend and I said
write me a song that sounds like Garth
Brooks and it gave me a different
version of Simple Man
so it's interesting that it would do
that but you're training it on these
copyrighted songs these MIDI files these
sound Technologies so as you do this who
owns the rights to that AI generated
material and using your technology could
I
remake a song insert content from my
favorite artist and then on the creative
rights to that song
thank you Senator uh this is an area of
great interest to us
I would say first of all we think that
creators deserve control over how their
Creations are used and
what happens sort of beyond the point of
them releasing it into the world
um second I think that we need to figure
out new ways with this new technology
that creators can win succeed have a
vibrant life and I'm optimistic that
this will present it then let me ask you
this how do you compensate the art the
artist that's exactly what I was going
to say okay
um we'd like to we're working with
artists now visual artists musicians uh
to figure out what people want there's a
lot of different opinions unfortunately
and at some point we'll have to let me
ask you this do you favor something like
Sound Exchange that has worked in the
area of radio I'm not familiar with live
exchange I'm sorry okay you've got your
team behind you get back to me on that
that would be a third party entity okay
so let's discuss that let me move on
um can you commit as you've done with
consumer data not to train chat GPT open
AI jukebox or other AI models on artists
and songwriters copyrighted works or use
their voices and their likenesses
without first receiving their consent so
first of all jukebox is not a product we
offer that was a research release but
it's not you know unlike chat GPT or
dollar but we've lived through Napster
yes
but that was something that really cost
a lot of artists a lot of money
oh I understand yeah for sure digital
distribution era I don't I don't know
the numbers on jukebox on the top of my
head as a research release I can I can
follow up with your office but it's not
jukebox is not something that gets much
attention or usage it was put out to to
show that something's possible well
Senator Durbin just said you know and I
think it's a fair warning to you all if
we're not involved in this from the
get-go and you all already are a long
way down the path on this but if we
don't step in then this gets away from
you so are you working with a copyright
office are you considering protections
for Content generators and creators in
generative AI yes we are absolutely
engaged on that again to reiterate my
earlier point we think that content
creators content owners need to benefit
from this technology exactly what the
economic model is we're still talking to
artists and content owners about I think
there's a lot of ways this can happen
but very clearly no matter what the law
is the right thing to do is to make sure
people get significant upside benefit
from this new technology and we believe
that it's really going to deliver that
but that content owners likenesses
people totally deserve control over how
that's used and to benefit from it okay
so on privacy then how do you plan to
account for for the collection of voice
and other user-specific data things that
are copyright righted user-specific data
through your AI applications because if
I can go in and say write me a song that
sounds like Garth Brooks and it takes
part of an existing song there has to be
a compensation to that artist for that
utilization and that use if it was radio
play it would be there if it was
streaming it would be there so if you're
going to do that what is your policy for
making certain you're accounting for
that and you're protecting that
individual's right to privacy and their
right to secure that data and that
created work so a few thoughts about
this uh number one we think that people
should be able to say I don't want my
personal data trained on
that's I think that's right that gets to
a national Privacy Law which many of us
here on the Deus are working toward
getting something that we can use yeah I
think a strong privacy my time's expired
look at yield back thank you Mr chip
thanks Senator Blackburn Senator
Klobuchar thank you very much Mr
chairman um and uh Senator Blackburn I
love Nashville I love Tennessee love
your music but I will say I use chat GPT
and just asked what are the top creative
song artists of all time and two of the
top three were from Minnesota that would
be uh Prince I'm sure they moved Prince
and Bob Dylan okay all right so let us
let us continue one thing AI won't
change and you're seeing it here all
right so on a more serious note though
my staff and I
um in my role as chair of the rules
committee and leading a lot of the
election bill and we just introduced a
bill that's
representative Yvette Clark from New
York introduced over the house Senator
Booker and Bennett and I did on
political advertisements but that is
just of course the tip of the iceberg
you know this from your discussions with
Senator Hawley and others about the
images and my own view it was Senator
Grahams of section 230 is that we just
can't let people make stuff up and then
not have any consequence but I'm going
to focus in on what my job one of my
jobs will be on the rules committee and
that is election misinformation and we
just asked Chef GPT to do a tweet about
a polling location in Bloomington
Minnesota and said there are long lines
at this polling location
at atonement Lutheran Church where
should we go now albeit it's not an
election right now but the answer the
tweet that was drafted was a completely
fake thing go to one two three four Elm
Street and so you can imagine what I'm
concerned about here with an election
upon us with primary elections upon us
that we're going to have all kinds of
misinformation and I just want to know
what you're planning on doing it doing
about it I know we're going to have to
do something soon not just for the
images of the candidates but also for
misinformation about the actual polling
place and election rules
thank you Senator that
we we talked about this a little bit
earlier we are quite concerned about the
impact this can have on elections I
think this is an area where hopefully
the entire industry and the government
can work together quickly
there's there's many approaches and I'll
talk about some of the things we do but
before that
I think it's tempting to use the frame
of social media
um but this is not social media this is
different and so the the response that
we need is different you know this is a
tool that a user is using to help
generate content more efficiently than
before they can change it they can test
the accuracy of it if they don't like it
they can get another version
um but it still then spreads through
social media or other ways like chat gbt
is a you know single player experience
where you're just using this
um
and so I think as we think about what to
do that's that's important to understand
there's a lot that we can and do do
there
um there's things that the model refuses
to generate we have policies uh we also
importantly have monitoring so at scale
uh we can detect someone generating a
lot of those tweets even if generating
one tweet is okay yeah and of course
there's going to be other platforms and
if they're all spouting out fake
election information I just that I think
what happened in the past with Russian
interference and like it's just going to
be a tip of the iceberg when some of
those fake ads so that's number one
number two is the impact on intellectual
property and Senator Blackburn was
getting at some of this with song rights
um and I have serious concerns about
that but news content so Senator Kennedy
and I have a bill that was really quite
straightforward that would simply
allowed the
um the news organizations an exemption
to be able to negotiate with basically
Google and Facebook Microsoft was
supportive of the bill but basically
negotiate with them to get better rates
and be able to not have some leverage
and other countries are doing this
Australia and the like and so my
question is when we already have a study
by Northwestern predicting that
one-third of the U.S newspapers are that
roughly existed two decades are going to
go are going to be gone by 2025 unless
you start compensating for everything
from book movies books yes but also news
content we're going to lose any
realistic content producers and so I'd
like your response to that and of course
there is an exemption for copyright in
section 230 but I think asking little
newspapers to go out and Sue all the
time just can't be the answer they're
not going to be able to keep up yeah
like
it is my hope that tools like what we're
creating can help news organizations do
better I think having a vibrant
having a vibrant National media is
critically important and let's call it
round one of the internet has not been
great for that right we're talking here
about local that you know report on your
high school football scores and a
scandal in your city council those kinds
of things for sure they're the ones that
are actually getting the worst the
little radio stations and broadcast but
do you understand that this could be
exponentially worse in terms of local
news content if they're not compensated
well because what they need is to be
compensated for their content and not
have it stolen yeah again our our model
you know our the current version of uh
gpt4 ended training in 2021 it's not
it's not it's not a good way to find
recent news uh and it's I don't think
it's a service that can do a great job
of linking out although maybe with our
plugins it's it's possible uh if there
are things that we can do to help local
news we would certainly like to again I
think it's it's critically important
okay
um May I add something there yeah but
let me just ask you a question you can
combine them quick more transparency on
the platforms
um Senator Coons and Sutter Cassidy and
I have the platform accountability
transparency act to give researchers
access to this information of the
algorithms and the like on social media
data would that be helpful and then why
don't you just say yes or no and then go
at his uh the transparency is absolutely
critical here to understand the
political ramifications the bias
ramifications and so forth we need
transparency about the data we need to
know more about how the models work we
need to have scientists have access to
them I was just going to amplify your
earlier point about local news a lot of
news is going to be generated by these
systems they're not reliable News Guard
already is a study I'm sorry it's not in
my appendix but I will get it to your
office showing that something like 50
websites are already
generated by Bots we're going to see
much much more of that and it's going to
make it even more competitive for the
local news organizations and so the
quality of the sort of overall news
Market is going to decline as we have
more generated content by systems that
aren't actually reliable in the content
they're generated thank you and thank
you at a very timely basis to make the
argument why we have to mark up this
bill again in June I appreciate it thank
you
Senator Graham
thank you Mr chairman and Senator Hawley
for having this I'm trying to find out
how it is different than social media
and learn
from the mistakes we made with social
media the idea of not suing social media
companies is to allow the internet to
flourish because
if I slander you you can sue me
if you're a billboard company and you
put up the slander can you sue the
billboard company we said no
basically section 230 is being used by
social media companies to high to avoid
liability uh for activity that other
people generate
when they refuse to comply with their
terms of use a mother calls up the
company and says this app is being used
to bully my child to death you promise
in the terms of use you would prevent
bullying
and she calls three times she gets no
response the child kills herself and
they can't sue
do you all agree we don't want to do
that again
yes
if I may speak for one second there's a
fundamental distinction between
reproducing content and generating
content
yeah but you you would like liability
where people are harmed absolutely
yes in fact IBM has been publicly
advocating to condition liability on a
reasonable Care standard so let me just
make sure I understand the law as it
exists today Mr Alman thank you for
coming your company is not claiming that
section 230 applies to the tool you have
created
yeah we're claiming we need to work
together to find a totally new approach
I don't think section 230 is that even
the right framework okay so under the
law it exists today this tool you create
if I'm harmed by it can I sue you
that is beyond my area of legalization
not for that no have you ever been sued
at all uh the your company yeah I get
sued uh yeah we've gotten sued before
okay and what for
um
I mean they've mostly been like pretty
frivolous things like I think happens to
any company but like the examples my
colleagues have given from artificial
intelligence that could literally ruin
our lives
can we go to the company that created
that tool in suom is that your
understanding yeah I think there needs
to be clear responsibility by the
companies but you're not claiming any
kind of legal protection
like section 2 the 230 applies to your
industry is that correct no I don't
think we're I don't I don't think we're
saying anything Mr Marcus um when it
comes to Consumers there seems to be
like three time tested ways to protect
consumers against any product
um statutory schemes which are
non-existent here
um
legal systems which may be appear here
but not social media and agencies
go back to
Senator Hawley the atom bomb
has put a cloud over Humanity
but nuclear power could be one of the
solutions to climate change
so what I'm trying to do is make sure
that you just can't go build a nuclear
power plant hey Bob what would you like
to do today let's go build a nuclear
power plant you have a nuclear
Regulatory Commission that governs
how you build a plant
and it's licensed do you agree Mr
Alderman that these tools you're
creating should be licensed yeah we've
been calling for this we think any
that's the simplest way you get a
license and do you agree with me the the
simplest way and the most effective way
is have an agency that is more Nimble
and smarter than Congress which should
be easy to create
overlooking what you do yes we'd be
enthusiastic about that you agree with
that Mr Marcus absolutely do you agree
with that that's Montgomery
I would have some nuances I think we
need to build on what we have in place
already today we don't have an agency
Regulators wait a minute nope nope nope
we don't have an agency that regulates
the technology so should we have one but
a lot of the issues I I don't think so a
lot of these wait a minute wait a minute
so IBM says we don't need an agency uh
interesting should we have a license
required for these tools so so what we
believe is that we need to write a
simple question should you get a license
to produce one of these tools I think it
comes back to some of them potentially
yes so what I said at the onset is that
we need to um clearly Define risks
you claim section 230 applies in this
area at all we are not a platform
company and we've again long advocated
for a reasonable Care standard in
section I just don't understand how you
could say
that you don't need an agency to deal
with the most transformative technology
maybe ever
well
a transformative technology that can
disrupt Life as we know it good and bad
I think it's a transformative technology
certainly and the conversations that
we're having here today have been really
bringing to light the fact that this is
the domains and the issues this one with
you has been very enlightening to me Mr
Allman why are you so willing to have an
agency
Senator we've been clear about what we
think the upsides are and I think you
can see from users how much they enjoyed
how much value they're getting out of it
but we've also been clear about what the
downsides are and so that's why we think
we need an agency system it's a major
tool to be used by a lot it's a major
new technology
yeah if you make a ladder and the ladder
doesn't work you can see the people made
the letter but there are some standards
out there to make a letter so that's why
we're agreeing with you yeah that's
right I think you're on the right track
so here's what my two cents worth for
the committee is that we need to empower
an agency
that issues in a license and can take it
away
wouldn't that be some incentive to do it
right if you could actually be taken out
of business it's clear that should be
part of what an agency can do now
and you also agree that China is doing
AI research is that right correct
this world organization that doesn't
exist maybe it will but if you don't do
something about the China part of it
you'll never quite get this right do you
agree
well that that's why I think it doesn't
necessarily have to be a world
organization but there has to be some
sort of and there's a lot of options
here there has to be some sort of
standard some sort of set of controls
that do have Global Effect you know
because you know other people doing this
I got 15 military application
how can AI change the Warfare
and you got one minute
I got one minute yeah all right this is
that's a tough question for one minute
um this is very far out of my area of
expertise uh but I give you one example
a drone can a drone you program you can
plug into a drone the coordinates and it
can fly out it goes over this Target and
it drops a missile on this car moving
down the road and somebody's watching it
could AI create a situation where a
drone can select the target itself I
think we shouldn't allow that well can
it be done sure thanks
underground Senator
thank you Senator Blumenthal Senator
Hawley for convening this hearing for
working closely together to come up with
this compelling panel of witnesses and
beginning a series of hearings on this
transformational technology but we
recognize the immense promise and
substantial risks associated with
generative AI Technologies we know these
models can make us more efficient help
us learn new skills open whole new
vistas of creativity but we also know
that generative AI can authoritatively
deliver wildly incorrect information it
can hallucinate as is often described it
can impersonate loved ones it can
encourage self-destructive behaviors and
it can shape public opinion and the
outcome of Elections Congress thus far
has demonstrably failed to responsibly
enact meaningful regulation of social
media companies with serious harms that
have resulted that we don't fully
understand Senator Globus referenced in
her questioning a bipartisan bill that
would open up social media platforms
underlying algorithms we have struggled
to even do that to understand the
underlying technology and then to move
towards responsible regulation we cannot
afford to be as late to responsibly
regulating generative AI as we have been
to social media because the consequences
both positive and negative will exceed
those of social media by orders of
magnitude so let me ask a few questions
designed to get at both how we assess
the risk what's the role of
international regulation and how does
this impact AI Mr Altman I appreciate
your testimony about the ways in which
open AI assesses the safety of your
models through a process of iterative
deployment the fundamental question
embedded in that process though is how
you decide whether or not a model is
safe enough to deploy and safe enough to
have been built and then let go into the
the wild I understand one way to prevent
generative AI models from providing
harmful content is to have humans
identify that content and then train the
algorithm to avoid it there's another
approach that's called constitutional AI
that gives the model a set of values or
principles to guide its decision making
would it be more effective to give
models these kinds of rules instead of
trying to require or compel training the
model on all the different potentials
for harmful content
thank you Senator it's it's a great
question uh I'd like to frame it by
talking about why we deploy at all like
why we put these systems out into the
world there's the obvious answer about
there's benefits and people are using it
for all sorts of wonderful things and
getting great value and that makes us
happy but a big part of why we do it is
that we believe that iterative
deployment and giving people on our
institutions and you all time to come to
grips with this technology to understand
it to find its limitations and benefits
that the regulations we need around it
what it takes to make it safe that's
really important going off to build a
super powerful AI system in secret and
then dropping it on the world all at
once I think would not go well so a big
part of our strategy is while these
systems are still relatively weak and
deeply imperfect to find ways to get
people to have experience with them to
have contact with reality and to figure
out what we need to do to make it safer
and better and that is the only way that
I've seen in the history of new
technology and products of this
magnitude to get to a very good outcome
and so that that interaction with the
world is very important now of course
before we put something out uh it needs
to meet a bar of safety and uh and again
we spent well over six months with gpt4
after we finished training it going
through all of these different things
and deciding also what the standards
were going to be before we put something
out there trying to find the harms that
we knew about uh put it and and how to
address those one of the things that's
been gratifying to us is even some of
our biggest critics have looked at gpt4
and said wow open AI made huge progress
on good Focus briefly on whether or not
a constitutional model that gives values
would be worth it I was just about to
get there all right sorry about that
um
yeah I think giving the models values up
front uh is an extremely important
Set uh you know rlhf is another way of
doing that same thing but somehow or
other you are with synthetic data or
human generated data you're saying here
are the values here's what I want you to
reflect or here are the wide bounds of
everything that Society will allow and
then within there you pick as the user
you know if you want value system over
here or value system over there
um we think that's very important
there's multiple technical approaches
but
we need to give policy makers and the
world as a whole the tools to say here's
the values and Implement them thank you
Ms Montgomery you serve on an AI ethics
Board of a long established company that
has a lot of experience with AI I'm
really concerned that generative AI
Technologies can undermine the faith of
democratic values and the institutions
that we have the Chinese are insisting
that AI as being developed in China
reinforce the core values of the Chinese
Communist Party in the Chinese system
and I'm concerned about how we
promote AI that reinforces and
strengthens open markets open societies
and democracy in your testimony you're
advocating for AI regulation tailored to
the specific way the technology is being
used not the underlying technology
itself and the EU it's moving ahead with
an AI act which categorizes AI products
based on level of risk you all in
different ways have said that you view
elections and the shaping of election
outcomes and disinformation that can
influence elections as one of the
highest risk cases one that's entirely
predictable we have attempted so far
unsuccessfully to regulate social media
after the demonstrably harmful impacts
of social media on our last several
elections what advice do you have for us
about what kind of approach we should
follow and whether or not the EU
direction is the right one to pursue
I mean the conception of the EU AI Act
is very consistent with this concept of
precision regulation where you're
regulating the use of the technology in
context so absolutely that approach
makes a ton of sense it's what
um I advocated for at the onset
different rules for different risks so
in the case of Elections absolutely any
algorithm being used in that context
should be required to have disclosure
around the data being used the
performance of the model anything along
those lines is really important guard
rails need to be in place and and on the
point just come back to the question of
of whether we need an independent agency
I mean I think we don't want to slow
down regulation to address real risks
right now right so we have existing
regulatory authorities in place who have
been clear that they have the ability to
regulate in their respective domains a
lot of the issues we're talking about
today span multiple domains elections
and the like so if I could I'll just
assert that those existing regulatory
bodies and authorities are
under-resourced and lack many of the
statutes regulatory powers that they
need correct we have failed to deliver
our data privacy even though industry
has asking us to regulate data privacy
if I might Mr Marcus I'm I'm interested
also what international bodies are best
positioned to convene multilateral
discussions to promote responsible
standards we've talked about a model
being CERN and nuclear energy I'm
concerned about proliferation and
non-proliferation we've also talked I
would suggest that the ipcc a U.N body
helped at least provide a scientific
Baseline of what's happening in climate
change so that even though we may
disagree about strategies globally we've
come to a common understanding of what's
happening and what should be the
direction of intervention I'd be
interested Mr Marcus if you could just
give us
um your thoughts on who's the right body
internationally to convene a
conversation and one that could also
reflect our values I'm still feeling my
way on that issue I think global
politics is not my specialty I'm an AI
researcher but I I've moved towards
policy in in recent months really
because of my great concern about all of
these risks I think certainly the UN
UNESCO has its guidelines should be
involved and at the table and maybe
things work under them and maybe they
don't but they should have a strong
voice and and help to develop this the
oacd has also been thinking greatly
about this number of organizations have
internationally I I don't feel like I
personally am qualified to say exactly
what the right model is there well thank
you I think we need to pursue this both
at the national level and the
international level I'm the chair of the
IP subcommittee of the Judiciary
Committee in June and July we will be
having hearings on the impact of AI on
patents and copyrights you can already
tell from the questions of others there
will be a lot of interest I look forward
to following up with you about that
topic I know Mr chairman I look forward
to helping as much as possible thank you
very much thanks Senator Coons Senator
Kennedy
thank you all for being here
permit me to share with you three
hypotheses that I would like you
to assume for the moment to be true
hypothesis number one
many members of Congress do not
understand
artificial intelligence
hypothesis number two
that absence of understanding
may not prevent Congress
from plunging in with enthusiasm
and trying to regulate this technology
in a way that could hurt this technology
hypothesis number three that I would
like you to assume
there is likely
a berserk wing of the artificial
intelligence community
that intentionally or unintentionally
could use artificial intelligence
to kill all of us and hurt us the entire
time that we are dying
assume all of those to be true
please tell me in plain English
two or three reforms regulations if any
that you would you would Implement if
you were queen or King for a Day
Ms Montgomery
I think it comes back again to
transparency and explainability in AI we
absolutely need to know and have
companies attest what do you mean by
transparency so disclosure of the data
that's used to train AI disclosure of
the model and how it performs and making
sure that there's continuous governance
over these models that we are the
Leading Edge into governance Foundation
technology governance organizational
governance
rules and clarification that are needed
that this which Congress I mean this is
your chance folks to tell us how to get
this right please use it
right I mean I think again the rules
should be focused on the use of AI in
certain contexts so if you look at for
example so if you look at the EU AIS it
has certain
uses of AI that it says are just simply
too dangerous and will be outlawed in
these okay so we ought to first pass the
law that says you can use AI
for these uses but not others is that is
that what you're saying we need to
define the highest risk usage is there
anything else
um and then of course uh requiring
things like impact assessments and
transparency requiring companies to show
their work
protecting data that's used to train AI
in the first place as well Professor
Marcus if you could be specific
this is your shot man
talking plain English and tell me what
if any rules we ought to implement and
please don't just use Concepts I'm
looking for specificity number one a
safety review like we use with the FDA
prior to widespread deployment if you
can introduce something to 100 million
people somebody has to have their
eyeballs on it there you go okay that's
a good one number sure I agree with it
but that's a good one what else you
didn't ask for three that you would
agree with number two
a Nimble monitoring agency to follow
what's going on not just pre-review but
also post as things are out there in the
world with authority to call things back
which we've discussed today and number
three would be funding geared towards
things like AI Constitution AI that can
reason about what it's doing I would not
leave things entirely to current
technology which I think is poor at
behaving in ethical fashion and behaving
in honest fashion and so I would have
funding to try to basically focus on AI
Safety Research that term has a lot of
complications in my field there's both
safety let's say short term and long
term and I think we need to look at both
rather than just funding models to be
bigger which is the popular thing to do
we need to find models to be more
trustworthy because I want to hear from
Mr Alton Mr Altman here's your shot
thank you Senator uh number one I would
form a new agency that licenses any
effort above a certain scale of
capabilities and can take that license
away and ensure compliance with safety
standards number two I would create a
set of safety standards focused on what
you said in your third hypothesis as the
dangerous capability evaluations one
example that we've used in the past is
looking to see if a model can
self-replicate and self-exfiltrate into
the wild we can give your office a long
other list of the things that we think
are important there but specific tests
that a model has to pass before it can
be deployed into the world and then
third I would require independent audits
so not just from the company or the
agency but experts who can say the model
is or isn't in compliance with these
stated safety thresholds and these
percentages of performance on question X
or Y
can you send me that information we will
do that
um would you be qualified
to uh to to uh if we promulgated those
rules to administer those rules I love
my current job
cool are there people out there that
would be qualified we'd be happy to send
you recommendations for people out there
yes okay
making a lot of money do you I make no I
paid enough for health insurance I have
no equity in open AI really yeah that's
interesting you need a lawyer I need a
what you need a lawyer or an agent I I'm
doing this because I love it
thank you Mr chairman thanks Senator
Kennedy uh senator hirono
thank you Mr chairman
listening to to all of you testifying
thank you very much for being here
clearly AI truly is a game-changing tool
and uh we need to get the regulation of
this tool right because my staff for
example asks AI it might have been gpt4
it might have been I don't know one of
the other
entities to create a song that my
favorite band BTS
a favorite a song that they would sing
somebody else's song but you know
neither of the artists were involved in
creating what sounded like a really
genuine song so you can do a lot we also
asked can
um can there be a speech created talking
about the the Supreme Court decision in
Dobbs and the chaos that it created
using my voice my kind of voice and it
created a speech that was really good it
almost made me think about you know what
do I need my staff for so
don't worry that's not very nervous
laughter behind you oh
their jobs are safe but there's so much
that can be done and one of the things
that you mentioned Mr May Altman that
intrigued me was you said gpd4 can
refuse harmful requests so you must have
put some thought into how your system if
I can call it that can refuse harmful
requests what what do you consider a
harmful request you can just keep it
short yeah uh
I'll give a few examples uh one would be
about violent content another would be
about content that's encouraging
self-harm another is adult content not
that we think adult content is
inherently harmful but there's things
that could be associated with that that
we cannot reliably enough differentiate
so we refuse all of it so those are some
of the more obvious harmful kinds of of
information but in the election context
for for example I saw a picture of a
former president Trump being arrested by
NY PD and that went viral I don't know
is that considered harmful I've seen all
kinds of statements attributed to any
one of us that could be put out there
that may not be that may not rise to
your level of harmful content but there
you have it so two of two of you said
that we should have a licensing scheme I
can't Envision or imagine right now what
kind of our licensing scheme we would be
able to create to pretty much regulate
the vastness of of the this game to
changing tools so
are you thinking of an FTC kind of a
system an FCC kind of a system what do
the two of you even Envision as a
potential licensing scheme that would
provide the kind of guard Wheels
that we need to protect our literally
our country from harmful content to
touch on the first part of what what you
said there are things besides uh you
know should this content be generated or
not that I think are also important so
that image that you mentioned was
generated I think it'd be a great policy
to say generated images need to be made
clear in all contexts that they were
generated and you know then we still
have the image out there but it's we're
at least requiring people to say this
was a generated image
make that where I think the licensing
scheme comes in is uh not with not for
what these models are capable of today
because as you pointed out you don't
need a new licensing agency to do that
but as we as we head and you know this
may take a long time I'm not sure as we
head towards artificial general
intelligence
and the impact that will have and the
power of that technology I think we need
to treat that as seriously as we treat
other very powerful Technologies and
that's where I personally think we need
such a such a scheme I agree and that is
why though by the time we're talking
about AGI we're talking about uh major
harms that can occur through the use of
AGI so
um Professor Marcus having what kind of
a regulatory scheme would you envision
and what and we can't just come up with
something you know that is going to be
of uh take care of the issues that will
arise in the future especially with AGI
so what is what kind of a scheme would
you contemplate well first if I can
rewind just a moment um I think you
really put your finger on the central
scientific issue in terms of the
challenges in building artificial
intelligence we don't know how to build
a system that understands harm in the
full breadth of its meaning so what we
do right now is We Gather examples and
we say is this like the examples that we
have labeled before but that's not broad
enough and so I thought you're
questioning beautifully outlined the
challenge that AI itself has to face in
order to to Really deal with this we
want AI itself to understand harm and
that may require new technology so I
think that's very important on this
second part of your question the model
that I turn they gravitate towards but I
am not an expert here is the FDA at
least as part of it in terms of you have
to make a safety case and say why the
benefits out weigh the Harms in order to
get that license probably we need
elements of multiple agencies I'm not an
expert there but I think that the safety
case part of it is incredibly important
you have to be able to have external
reviewers that are scientifically
qualified look at this and say you have
you addressed enough so I'll just give
one specific example Auto GPT frightens
me that's not something that open AI
made but something that openai did make
call called chat GPD plugins led a few
weeks later to some Building open source
software called Auto GPT and what Auto
GPT does is it allows systems to access
source code access the internet and so
forth and there are a lot of potential
let's say cyber security risks there
there should be an external agency that
says well we need to be reassured if
you're going to release this product
that there aren't going to be cyber
security problems or there are ways of
addressing it so Professor I am running
Montgomery your
model is the the use model similar to
what the EU has come up with but the
vast vastness of AI and the complexities
involved I think would require more than
looking at the use use of it and I think
that based on what I'm hearing today
don't you think that that uh we're
probably going to need to do a heck of a
lot more than to focus on what use it as
being AI is being used for for example
you can ask AI to come up with a funny
joke or something but you can use the
same you can ask the same AI tool to
generate something that is like an
election fraud kind of a situation so I
don't know how you will make a
determination based on where you're
going with the use model how to
distinguish those kinds of uses of this
tool so I think that if we're going to
go toward a licensing kind of a scheme
we're going to need to put a lot of
thought into how we're going to come up
with an appropriate scheme that is going
to provide the kind of future reference
that we need to put in place so I I
thank all of you for coming in and
providing further food for thought thank
you Mr chairman
thanks very much Senator corono uh
Senator Padilla
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate the
flexibility as I've been uh back and
forth to uh maintain this committee and
Homeland Security committee where
there's a hearing going on right now on
the use of AI in government so it's AI
day on the hill or at least the Senate
apparently now for folks watching at
home if you never thought about AI until
the recent emergence of genitive AI
tools the developments in this space may
feel like they've just happened all of a
sudden
but the fact of the matter is Mr chairs
that they haven't AI is not new not for
government not for business not for
public not for the public in fact the
public uses AI all the time and just for
folks to be able to relate want to offer
the example of anybody with a smartphone
uh many features on your device leverage
AI including suggested replies right
over text messaging or even to email
autocorrect features including but not
limited to spelling in her email and
text applications so I'm frankly excited
to explore how we can facilitate
positive AI Innovation that benefits
Society while addressing some of the
already known harms and biases that stem
from the development and the use of the
tools today
now with language models becoming
increasingly ubiquitous I want to make
sure that there's a focus on ensuring
Equitable treatment of diverse
demographic groups my understanding is
that most research in to evaluating and
mitigating fairness harms has been
concentrated
on the English language while
non-english languages have received
comparatively little attention or
investment and we've seen this problem
before I'll tell you why I raised this
social media companies for example have
not adequately invested in content
moderation tools and resources for their
non-english uh in in non-english
language and I said it's not just out of
concern for non-us-based users but
so many us-based users prefer a language
other than English in their
communication
so I'm deeply concerned about repeating
social media's failure in AI tools and
applications question Mr Altman and Miss
Montgomery how are open Ai and IBM
ensuring Language and Cultural
inclusivity that they're in their uh
large language models
and it's even an area of focusing the
development of your products
so bias and equity in technology is a
focus of ours and always has been I
think diversity in terms of the
development of the tools in terms of
their deployment so having diverse
people that are actually training those
tools considering the downstream effects
as well we're also very cautious uh very
aware of the fact that we can't just be
articulating and calling for these types
of things without having the tools and
the technology to test for bias and to
apply governance across the life cycle
of AI so we were one of the first teams
and companies to put tool kits on the
market deploy them contribute them to
open source that will do things like
help to address you know be the
technical aspects in which we help to
address issues like bias
can you speak just for a second
specifically to language inclusivity
yeah I mean language so we don't have a
consumer platform but we are very
actively involved with ensuring that the
technology we hope to deploy in the
large language models that we use in
helping our clients to deploy technology
is focused on and available in many
languages thank you the shop we think
this is really important one example is
that we worked with the government of
Iceland which is a language with fewer
speakers than many of the languages that
are well represented on the internet to
ensure that their language was included
in our model and we've had many similar
conversations and I look forward to many
similar Partnerships with lower resource
languages to get them into our models
gpt4 is uh unlike previous models of
ours which were good at English and not
very good at other languages uh now
pretty good at a large number of
languages you can go pretty far down the
list ranked by number of speakers and
still get good performance but for these
very small languages we're excited about
custom Partnerships to include that
language into our model run and the part
of the question you asked about values
and making sure that cultures are
included we're equally focused on that
excited to work with people who have
particular data sets and to work to
collect a representative set of values
from around the world to draw these wide
bounds of what the system can do I also
appreciate what you said about the the
benefits of these systems and wanting to
make sure we get those to as wide of a
group as possible I think this will
these systems will have lots of positive
impact on a lot of people but in
particular underrepresented
historically underpresented groups in
technology people who have not had as
much technology around the world this
technology seems like it can be a big
lift up
and uh I know my
question was specific to language
inclusivity but uh glad there's
agreement on the broader uh commitment
to uh diversity and inclusion and I'll
just give a couple more reasons why they
think it's so critical you know the
largest actors in this space can afford
the massive amount of data the computing
power and they have the financial
resources necessary to develop complex
AI systems
but in this space we haven't seen from a
Workforce standpoint the racial and
gender diversity reflective of the
United States of America and we risk if
we're not thoughtful about it uh
contributing to the development of tools
and approaches that only exacerbate the
bias and inequities that exist in our
society so a lot of follow-up work to do
there in my time remaining I do want to
ask one more question this committee and
the public are right to pay attention to
the emergence of generative AI now this
technology has a different opportunity
and a risk profile than other AI tools
and these applications have felt very
tangible for the public due to the
nature of the user interface and the
outputs that they produce
but I don't think we should lose that of
the broader AI ecosystem as we consider
ai's broader impact on society as well
as the design of appropriate safeguards
so miss Montgomery in your testimony uh
as you noted AI is not you can you
highlight some of the different
applications that the public and policy
makers should also keep in mind as we
consider possible regulations
yeah I mean I think the generative AI
systems that are available today are
creating new issues that neces that need
to be studied new issues around the
potential to generate content that could
be extremely misleading deceptive and
alike so those issues absolutely need to
be studied but we shouldn't also ignore
the fact that AI is a tool it's been
around for a long time it has
capabilities Beyond just generative
capabilities and again that's why I
think going back to this approach where
we're regulating AI where it's touching
people and Society is a really important
way to address it
thank you Mr chair
thanks Senator uh Senator Booker is next
but I think he's going to defer to
senator ossoff
is a very big deal I don't know
I have a meeting at noon and I'm
grateful to you Senator Booker for
yielding your time you are as always
brilliant and handsome and thank you to
the panelists for joining us thank you
to the subcommittee leadership for
opening us up to all committee members
if we're going to contemplate a
regulatory framework we're gonna have to
Define what it is that we're regulating
so uh you know Mr Alban any such law
will have to include a section that
defines the scope of regulated
activities Technologies tools products
just take a stab at it
yeah thanks for asking Senator also I
think I think it's super important I
think there are very different levels
here and I think it's important that any
any new approach any new law does not
stop the Innovation from happening with
smaller companies open source models
researchers that are doing work at a
smaller scale
that's a wonderful part of this
ecosystem in of America we don't want to
slow that down there still may need to
be some rules there but I think we could
draw
a line at systems that need to be
licensed in a very intense way the
easiest way to do it I'm not sure if
it's the best but the easiest would be
to talk about the amount of compute that
goes into such a model so we could
divide you know we could Define a
threshold of compute and it'll have to
go it'll have to change it could go up
or down I could down as we discover more
efficient algorithms that says above
this amount of compute you are in this
regime what I would prefer it's hard to
do but I think more accurate is to
Define some capability thresholds and
say a model that can do things X Y and Z
up to all to decide that's now in this
licensing regime but models that are
less capable you know we don't want to
stop our open source Community we don't
want to stop individual researchers we
don't want to stop new startups can
proceed you know with a different
framework thank you as concisely as you
can please state which capabilities
you'd propose would consider for the
purposes of this definition
uh I would love rather than to do that
off the cuff to follow up with your
office with like well perhaps openings
opine understanding that you're just
responding uh and you're not making a
law all right in the spirit of just a
pining um I think a model that can uh
persuade manipulate influence person's
Behavior or a person's beliefs that
would be a good threshold I think a
model that could help create novel
biological agents would be a great
threshold
things like that I want to talk about
the predictive capabilities of a
technology and we have to think about a
lot of very complicated constitutional
questions that arise from it
with with massive data sets
the integrity and accuracy with which
such technology can predict future human
behaviors potentially pretty significant
at the individual level correct
I think we don't know the answer to that
for sure but let's say it can at least
have some impact there okay so we may be
confronted by situations where for
example a law enforcement agency
deploying such technology seeks some
kind of judicial consent to execute a
search
or to take some other police action on
the basis of a modeled prediction about
some individual's Behavior Uh
but that's very different from the kind
of evidentiary predicate that normally
police would take to a judge in order to
get a warrant
talk me through how you think about that
issue
I think it's very important that we
continue to
understand that these are tools that
humans use to make human judgments and
that we don't take away human judgment I
don't think that people should be
prosecuted based off of the output of an
AI system for example we have no uh
National Privacy Law
uh the Europe has has rolled one out to
mixed reviews do you think we need one I
think it'd be good and what would be the
qualities or purposes of such a law that
you think would make the most sense
based on your experience
again this is very far out of my area of
expertise I think there's many many
people that could that are privacy
experts that could weigh on what a lot
needs I'd still like I'd still like you
to weigh in
um
I mean I think a minimum is that users
should be able to to sort of opt out
from having their data used by companies
like ours or the social media companies
it should be easy to delete your data I
think those are it should but the thing
that I think is important from my
perspective running an AI company is
that if you don't want your data used
for training these systems uh you have
the right to do that so let's think
about how that will be practically
implemented I mean uh
as I understand it your tool and
certainly similar tools one of the
inputs will be
um
scraping for lack of a better word data
off of the open web right as a low-cost
way of of gathering information and
there's a vast amount of information out
there about all of us how would such a
restriction on the access or use or
analysis of such data be practically
implemented so I was speaking about
something a little bit different which
is the data that someone generates the
questions they ask our system things
that they input their training on that
data that's on the public web that's
accessible even if we don't train on
that the models can certainly link out
to it so that was not what I was
referring to I think that
you know there's ways to have your data
or there should be more ways to have
your data taken down from the public web
but certainly models with web browsing
capabilities will be able to search the
web and Link out to it
when you think about implementing a
safety or a regulatory regime to
constrain such software and to mitigate
some risk
is your view that
the federal government
would make laws such that certain
capabilities or functionalities
themselves are forbidden in potential in
other words one cannot
uh
deploy or execute code capable of X yes
or is it the act itself X only when
actually executed well I think both I'm
a Believer in defense in depth I think
that there should be limits on what a
deployed model is capable of and then
what it actually does too how are you
thinking about how kids use your product
we well you have to be I mean you have
to be 18 or up or have your parents
permission at 13 and up to use a product
but we understand that people get around
those safeguards all the time and so we
try to do is just design a safe product
and there are decisions that we make
that we would allow if we knew only
adults were using it that we just don't
allow in the product because we know
children will use it some way or other
too in particular given how much these
systems are being used in education we
like want to be aware that that's
happening I think what and and Senator
Blumenthal has done extensive work
investigating this what we've seen
repeatedly is that companies whose
revenues depend upon volume of use
screen time intensity of use
design these systems in order to
maximize the engagement of all users
including children with with perverse
results in many cases and what I would
humbly advise you is that you get way
ahead of this issue the safety for
children of your product or I think
you're going to find that Senator
Blumenthal Senator Holly others on the
subcommittee and I
um are will look very harshly on the
deployment of technology that harms
children we couldn't agree more I think
we're out of time but I'm happy to talk
about that if I can respond go ahead
well it's up to the chairman
okay
um
I first of all I think we try to design
systems that do not maximize for
engagement in fact we're so short on
gpus the less people use our products
the better but we're not an Advertising
based model we're not trying to get
people to use it more and more
um
and I think that's that's a different
shape than ad supported social media
second uh
these systems do have the capability to
to influence in obvious and in very
nuanced ways and I think that's
particularly important for the safety of
children but that will that will impact
all of us one of the things that we'll
do ourselves uh regulation or not but I
think a regulatory approach would be
good for also is requirements about how
the values of these systems are set and
how these systems respond to questions
that can cause influence so we'd love to
partner with you couldn't agree more on
the importance thank you
Mr chairman for the record I just want
to say that the senator from Georgia is
also very handsome and Brilliant too
but I will uh allow that comment to
stand with without objection without
objection okay
um Mr chairman are now recognized thank
you very much thank you it's nice that
we finally got down to the ball guys
down here at the end
um I just want to thank you both this
has been one of the best hearings I've
had this Congress and uh just a
testimony to you to seeing uh the
challenges and the opportunities that AI
presents so I appreciate you both I want
to just jump in I think very broadly and
then I'll get a little more narrow uh
Sam you said very broadly technology has
been moving like this and we are a lot
of people have been talking about
regulation and so I use the example of
the automobile what an extraordinary uh
piece of technology I mean New York City
did not know what to do with horse
manure they were having crises forming
commissions and the automobile comes
along ends that problem but at the same
time we have tens of thousands of people
dying on highways every day we have
emissions crises and the like there are
multiple federal agencies multiple
federal agencies that were created uh or
are specifically focused on regulating
cars
um and and so this idea that this
equally transforming technology is
coming and for Congress to do nothing
which is not what anybody hears is is uh
calling for little or nothing is is
obviously unacceptable uh I really
appreciate uh Senator Welsh and I have
been going back and forth uh during this
hearing and him and Bennett have a bill
talking about trying to regulate in this
space not doing so for uh social media
uh has been I think very destructive and
allowed a lot of things uh to go on that
are really causing a lot of harm and so
the question is is what kind of
Regulation you all have spoken that to a
lot of my colleagues
um and and I want to say Miss Montgomery
and I have to give full disclosure I'm
the child of two IBM parents
um uh but I I you know you talked about
uh defining the highest risk uses we
don't know all of them we really don't
we can't see where this is going uh
regulating at the point of risk and you
you sort of
called not for an agency and I think
when you when somebody else asks you to
specify because you don't want to slow
things down we should build on what we
have in place but you can Envision that
we can try to work on two different ways
that ultimately a specific like we have
in uh in cars EPA Nitza the federal
motor car carrier safety administration
all of these things you can imagine
something specific that is uh as Mr
Marcus points out a Nimble agency that
could do monitoring other things you
could imagine the need for something
like that correct oh absolutely yeah and
and so uh just for the record then in
addition to trying to regulate with what
we have now you would encourage Congress
and my colleague Senator Welsh to move
forward in trying to figure out the
right tailored agency to deal with what
we know and perhaps things that might
come up in the future
I would encourage Congress to make sure
it understands the technology has the
skills and resources in place to impose
regulatory requirements on the uses of
the technology and to understand
emerging risks as well so yes yeah Mr
Marcus there's no way no way to put this
genie in the bottle globally this is
It's exploding I appreciate your
thoughts and I shared some with my staff
about your ideas what the international
context is but there's there's no way to
stop this moving forward so with that
understanding just building on what what
Miss Montgomery said what kind of
encouragement do you have as
specifically as possible to forming an
agency to using current rules and
regulations can you just put some
clarity on what you've already stated
let me just insert there are more Genies
yet to come from more bottles some
Genies are already out but we don't have
machines that can really for example
self-improve themselves we don't really
have machines that have self-awareness
and we might not ever want to go there
so there are other Genies to be
concerned about onto the main part of
your question
I think that we need to have some
International meetings very quickly with
people who have expertise in how you
grow agencies in the history of growing
agencies we need to do that in the
federal level we need to do that in the
international level I'll just emphasize
one thing I haven't as much as I would
like to which is that I think science
has to be a really important part of it
and I'll give an example we've talked
about misinformation we don't really
have the tools right now to detect and
label misinformation with nutrition
labels that we would like to we have to
build new technologies for that we don't
really have tools yet to detect a wide
uptick in cyber crime probably we
probably need new tools there we need
science to probably help us to figure
out what we need to build and also what
it is that we need to have transparency
around understood understood Sam just go
to you uh for the little bit of time I
have left real quick
um first of all you're a bit of a
unicorn when I sat down with you first
could you explain why non-profit in
other words you're you're you're you're
not looking this and you've even capped
the vce people just really quickly I
want folks to understand that
we started as a non-profit uh really
focused on how this technology was going
to be built at the time it was very
outside the Overton window that
something like AGI was even possible
that's that shifted a lot um we didn't
know at the time how important scale was
going to be but we did know that we
wanted to build this
um with Humanity's best interests at
heart and a belief that this technology
could if it goes the way we we want if
we can do some of those things for
Professor Marcus mentioned uh really
deeply transformed the world and we
wanted to be as much of a force for
getting to a positive I'm going to
interrupt you I think that's all good I
hope more of that gets out on the record
the second part of my question as well
um I found it fascinating uh but are you
ever gonna for a revenue model for
return on your investors are you ever
going to do ads or something like that
I wouldn't say never I don't think like
I think there may be people that we want
to offer services to and there's no
other model that works but I really like
having a subscription-based model uh we
have API developers pay us and we have
one of my biggest concerns about this
space is what I've already seen in the
space of uh web 2 web 3 is this massive
corporate concentration it is really
terrifying to see how few companies now
control and affect the lives of so many
of us and these companies are getting
bigger and more powerful and I see you
know open AI back by Microsoft uh
anthropic is backed by Google Google has
its own in-house products We Know bar so
I'm really worried about that and I'm
wondering uh if Sam you can give me a
quick uh acknowledgment are you worried
about the corporate concentration in
this space and what effect it might have
uh um uh and the associated risks
perhaps with Market concentration in Ai
and then Mr Market Marcus can you answer
that as well I think there will be many
people that develop models uh what's
happening on the open source Community
is amazing but there will be a
relatively small number of providers
that can make models at the at the
church
um I think there is
benefits and danger to that like as we
were talking about all the dangers with
AI the fewer of us that you really have
to keep a careful eye on on the absolute
like bleeding edge of capabilities
there's benefits there but then I think
there needs to be enough in their will
because there's so much value that
consumers have choice that we have
different ideas Mr Marcus real quick
there there is a real risk of a kind of
technical technocracy combined with
oligarchy where a small number of
companies influence people's beliefs
through the nature of these systems
again I put something in the wall in the
record about the Wall Street Journal
about how these systems can subtly shape
our beliefs and that's enormous
influence on how we live our lives and
having a small number of players do that
with data that we don't even know about
that scares me Sam I'm sorry one more
thing I wanted to add one thing that I
think is very important is that that
what these systems get aligned to
whose values what those bounds are that
that is somehow set by society as a
whole by governments as a whole and so
creating that data set the Align that
our alignment data set it could be you
know an AI Constitution whatever it is
that that has got to come very broadly
from society
thank you very much Mr chairman Thomas
expired and I guess the best for last
thank you Senator Booker Senator well
first of all I want to thank you Senator
Blumenthal and you Senator Holly this
has been a tremendous hearing uh
senators are noted for their short
attention spans but I've sat through
this entire hearing and enjoyed every
minute of it you have one of our longer
attention spans in the United States to
your great credit well we've had good
Witnesses and it's an incredibly
important issue and here's just I don't
all the questions I have have been asked
really but here's a kind of a takeaway
and what I think is the major question
that we're going to have to answer as a
congress
and number one you're here because AI is
this extraordinary new technology that
everyone says can be transformative as
much as the printing press
number two is really unknown what's
going to happen but there's a big fear
you've expressed to all of you about
what Bad actors can do and will do if
there's no rules of the road
uh number three
as a member who served in the house and
now in the Senate
I've come to the conclusion that it's
impossible for Congress to keep up with
the speed of Technology
and there have been concerns expressed
uh and so about social media and now
about a AI that relate to fundamental
privacy rights bias rights intellectual
property uh the spread of disinformation
which in many ways for me is the biggest
threat because that goes to the core of
our capacity for self-governing
uh there's the economic transformation
which can be profound through safety
concerns
and and I've come to the conclusion that
we absolutely have to have an agency
what it's
scope of Engagement is is has to be
defined by us
but
I believe that unless we have an agency
that is going to address these questions
from social media in AI
we really don't have much of a defense
against the bad stuff
and the bad stuff will come so uh last
year I introduced in the house side and
Senator Bennett didn't set aside it was
the end of the year digital commission
act and we're going to be reintroducing
that this year
and the two things that I want to ask
one you've somewhat answered because I
think two of the three of you have said
you think we do need an independent
commission you know and Congress
established it into independent
commission when railroads were running
rampant over the interest of farmers
when Wall Street had no rules of the
road and we had the SEC and I think
we're at that point now
but
what the commission does would have to
be defined and circumscribed but also
there's always a question about the use
of regulatory Authority
and the recognition that it can be used
for good JD Vance actually mentioned
that when we were considering his and
Senator Brown's Bill about railroads in
that event in East Palestine
regulation for the public health but
there's also a legitimate concern about
regulation getting in the way of things
being too cumbersome and being a
negative influence so a
two of the three of you have said you
think we do need an agency
uh what are some of the Perils of an
agency that we would have to be mindful
of in order to make certain that its
goals of protecting many of those
interests I just mentioned privacy bias
intellectual property disinformation
would be the winners and not the losers
and I'll start with you Mr Altman
thank you Senator uh
one I think America has got to continue
to lead
this happened in America I'm very proud
that it happened in America by the way I
I think that's right and that's why I'd
be much more confident if we had our
agency as opposed to got involved in
international discussions ultimately you
want the rules of the road but I think
if we lead and get rules of the road
that work for us that is probably a more
effective way to proceed I I I
personally believe there's a way to do
both and I think it is important to have
the global view on this because this
technology will impact Americans and all
of us wherever it's developed but I
think we want America to lead we want we
want so get to the perils issue though
because I know well that's one I mean
that is apparel which is you slow down
American industry in such a way that
China or somebody else makes faster
progress
a second and I think this can happen
with like
the regulatory pressure should be on us
it should be on Google it should be on
the other small set of people in the
lead the most we don't want to slow down
smaller startups we don't want to slow
down uh open source efforts we still
need them to comply with things they can
still you can still cause great harm
with a smaller model but leaving the
room and the space for new ideas and new
companies uh and independent researchers
to do their work and not put in a
regulatory burden to say a company like
us could handle but a smaller one
couldn't
um I think that's another Peril and it's
clearly a way that regulation has gone
okay Mr Marcus or Professor the other
obvious Peril is regulatory capture if
we make it as appear as if we are doing
something but it's more like green
washing and nothing really happens we
just keep out the little players because
we put so much burden that only the big
players can do it so there are also
those kinds of perils I fully agree with
everything that that Mr Altman said and
I would add that to the list
is Montgomery
one of the things I would add to the
list is the risk of not holding
companies accountable for the harms that
they're causing today right so we talk
about misinformation in electoral
systems so no agency or no agency we
need to hold companies responsible today
and accountable for AI that they're
deploying that disseminates
misinformation on things like elections
and where the where the risk you know
regulatory agency would do a lot of the
things that Senator Graham was talking
about you know you don't build a nuclear
reactor without getting a license you
don't build an AI system without getting
a license that gets tested independently
I think it's a great analogy we need
both pre-deployment pre-deployment and
post deployment okay thank you all very
much I yield back Mr chairman thanks
thanks Senator Welsh let me ask a few
more questions you've all been very very
patient and the turnout today which is
beyond our subcommittee I think reflects
both your
value in what you're contributing as
well as the interest in this topic uh
there are a number of subjects that we
haven't covered
at all but one was uh just alluded to
I
Professor Marcus which is the
monopolization danger
the dominance of markets that excludes
new competition and thereby inhibits or
prevents Innovation and invention which
we have seen in social media as well as
some of the old Industries Airlines
Automobiles and others where
consolidation has narrowed competition
and so uh I think we need to to focus on
kind of an old area of antitrust which
dates more than a century still
inadequate to deal with the challenges
we have right now in our economy and
certainly
we need to be mindful of the way that
rules can
enable the big guys to get bigger and
exclude Innovation and competition and
responsible
good guys
such as are represented
in this industry right now we haven't
dealt with National Security
they're huge implications for National
Security I will tell you as a member of
the armed services committee uh
classified briefings on this issue have
abounded
and the threats that are posed by some
of our
adversaries China has been mentioned
here
but the sources of threats to this
nation in this space are very real and
Urgent uh we're not going to deal with
them today but we do need to deal with
them and we will hopefully in this
committee and then uh on the issue of a
new agency you know I've been doing this
stuff for a while
I was Attorney General of Connecticut
for 20 years I was a federal prosecutor
the U.S attorney most of my career has
been in enforcement
and I will tell you something you can
create 10 new agencies
but if you don't give them the resources
and I'm talking not just about dollars
I'm talking about scientific expertise
you guys will run circles around them
and it isn't just the
the models or the generative AI that
will run models around run circles
around them but it is
the scientists in your company
for every success story in government
regulation you can think of five
failures
that's true of the FDA
it's true of the iaea it's true of the
SEC it's true of the whole alphabet list
of government agencies and I hope our
experience here will be different but
the Pandora's Box
requires more than just
the words or the concepts licensing
new agency
there's some real hard decision making
as Ms Montgomery has alluded to about
how to frame the rules to fit the risk
first Do no harm
make it effective make it enforceable
make it real
I think we need to Grapple with
the the hard questions here that you
know frankly this initial hearing I
think is raised very successfully but
not answered and I I thank our
colleagues who have participated and and
made these uh very creative suggestions
I'm very interested in uh enforcement I
you know literally 15 years ago I think
advocated abolishing section 230.
what's old is New Again
you know now people are talking about
abolishing section 230 back then it was
considered completely unrealistic but uh
enforcement really does matter I want to
ask uh Mr Altman because of the the
Privacy issue and you suggested uh that
you have an interest in protecting the
privacy of the data that may come to you
or be available how do you What specific
steps you take
uh to protect privacy
uh one is that we don't train on any
data submitted to our API so if you're a
business customer of ours and submit
data we don't train it at all we do
retain it for 30 days solely for the
purpose of trust and safety enforcement
um but that's different than training
and I if you use chat GPT you can opt
out of us training on your data you can
also delete your conversation history or
your whole account
um Miss Montgomery I know you don't deal
directly with consumers but do you take
steps to protect privacy as well
absolutely and we even filter our large
language models for Content that
includes personal information that may
have been pulled from public data sets
as well so we apply additional level of
filtering
um Professor Marcus you made reference
to self-awareness
self-learning uh already we're talking
about the potential for jailbreaks
um
how soon do you think that new kind of
generative
AI will be
usable will be practical
new AI that is self-aware and so forth
where yes I mean I have no idea on that
one I think we don't really understand
what self-awareness is and so it's hard
to put a date on it in terms of
self-improvement there's some modest
self-improvement in current systems but
one could imagine a lot more and that
could happen in two years it could
happen in 20 years the basic paradigms
that haven't been invented yet some of
them we might want to discourage but
it's a bit hard to put timelines on them
and just going back to enforcement for
one second one thing that is absolutely
Paramount I think is far greater
transparency about what the models are
and what the data are that doesn't
necessarily mean everybody in the
general public has to know exactly
what's in one of these systems but I
think it means that there needs to be
some enforcement arm that can look at
these systems can look at the data can
perform tests and so forth
um let me ask you uh all of you uh
I think there has been a reference to
um elections and banning
um
outputs involving elections are there
other areas where you think what are the
what are the other high risk or highest
risk areas where you would
either ban or establish especially
strict rules
Miss Montgomery
the space around misinformation I think
is hugely important one and coming back
to the points of transparency you know
knowing what content was generated by AI
is going to be a really critical area
that we need to address
any others I think medical
misinformation is something to really
worry about we have systems that
hallucinate things they're going to
hallucinate medical advice some of the
advice they'll give is good some of it's
bad we need really tight regulation
around that same with psychiatric
advice people using these things as as
kind of erzot's therapists I think we
need to be very concerned about that I
think we need to be concerned about
internet access for these tools when
they can start making requests both of
people and and internet things is
probably okay if they just do search but
as they do more intrusive things on the
internet like do we want them to be able
to order equipment or order chemistry
and so forth so as they as we Empower
these systems more by giving them
internet access I think we need to be
concerned about that and then we've
hardly talked at all about long-term
risk Sam alluded to it briefly I don't
think that's where we are right now but
as we start to approach machines that
have a larger footprint on the world
Beyond just having a conversation we
need to worry about that and think about
how we're going to Reg regulate that and
monitor it and so forth in a sense we've
been talking about
bad guys or
um
certain Bad actors manipulating
AI to do harm manipulating people and
manipulating people but also
generative AI can manipulate the
manipulators
it it can I mean there's there's many
layers of manipulation that are possible
and I think we don't yet really
understand the consequences Dan Dennett
just sent me a manuscript last night
that will be in the Atlantic in a few
days on what he calls counterfeit people
it's a wonderful metaphor these systems
are almost like counterfeit people and
we don't really honestly understand what
the consequence of that is they're not
perfectly human like yet but they're
good enough to fool a lot of the people
a lot of the time and that introduces
lots of problems for example cyber crime
and how people might try to manipulate
markets and so forth so it's a serious
concern in my opening I
suggested three principles
transparency
accountability
and limits on use
would you agree that those are a good
starting point
is Montgomery 100 and as you also
mentioned industry shouldn't wait for
congress that's what we're doing here at
IBM there's no reason that absolutely
wait for congress yep Professor Marcus I
think those three would be a great start
I mean there are there are things like
the White House Bill of Rights for
example that show I think a large
consensus the UNESCO guidelines and so
forth so a large consensus around what
it is we need and the real question is
definitely now how are we going to put
some teeth in it try to make these
things actually enforce so for example
we don't have transparency yet we all
know we want it but we're not doing
enough to enforce it
Mr Altman I certainly agree that those
are important points I would add that
and Professor Marcus touched on this I
would add that as we
we spend most of the time today on
current risks and I think that's
appropriate I'm very glad we have done
it as these systems do become more
capable and I'm not sure how far away
that is but maybe not not super far I
think it's important that we also spend
time talking about how we're going to
confront those challenges I mean talk to
you privately you know how much I care I
agree that you care deeply and intensely
but also
that Prospect of increased danger or
risk resulting from even more
complex and capable
AI mechanisms certainly maybe closer
than a lot of people appreciate so let
me just add for the record that I'm
sitting next to Sam closer than I've
ever sat to him except once before in my
life and that his sincerity in talking
about those fears is very apparent
um physically in a way that just doesn't
communicate on the television screen but
communicates from here thank you Senator
Hawley thank you again Mr chairman for a
great hearing thanks to the witnesses so
I've been keeping a little list here of
the potential downsides or harms risks
of generative AI even in its current
form let's just run through it loss of
jobs
and this isn't speculative I think your
company Miss Montgomery's announced that
it's it's potentially laying off 7 800
people a third of your non-consumer
facing Workforce for because of AI so
loss of jobs invasion of privacy
personal privacy on a scale we've never
before seen manipulation of personal
Behavior manipulation of personal
opinions and potentially the degradation
of free elections in America did I miss
anything
I mean this is this is quite a list
I noticed that an Eclectic group of
about a thousand technology and AI
leaders everybody from Andrew Yang to
Elon Musk recently called for a
six-month moratorium on any further AI
development
were they right do you join those calls
are you right to do that should we
should we pause for six months
characterization's not quite correct um
I actually signed that letter about 27
000 people signed it
um it did not call for a ban on all AI
research it only called in nor on all AI
but only on a very specific thing which
would be systems like gpt5
um every other piece of research that's
ever been done it was actually
supportive or neutral about and
specifically called for more AI sorry
specifically called for more research on
trustworthy and safe AI so you think
just so you think that we should take a
moratorium a six-month moratorium or
more on anything beyond chat gpt4 I took
the letter what is the famous phrase uh
spiritually not literally what was the
famous phrase
um well I'm asking for your opinion now
though so my opinion is that the
moratorium that we should focus on is
actually deployment until we have good
safety cases I'd don't know that we need
to pause that particular project but I
do think it's emphasis on focusing more
on AI safety on trustworthy reliable AI
is that exactly right deployment means
not making it available to public yeah
my concern is about things that are
deployed at a scale of let's say 100
million people without any external
review I think that we should think very
carefully about doing that
what about you Mr Altman do you agree
with that would you would you pause any
further development for six months or
longer uh so first of all we after we
finish training gpt4 we waited more than
six months to deploy it um we are not
currently training what will be gpd5 we
don't have plans to do it in the next
six months but I think the frame of the
letter is wrong what matters is
audits
red teaming safety standards that a
model needs to pass before training if
we pause for six months then I'm not
what we sure share what we do then do we
pause for another six do we kind of come
up with some rules then the standards
that we have developed and that we've
used for
gpt4 deployment uh we want to build on
those but we think that's the right
direction uh not a calendar clock pause
there may be times I expect there will
be times when we find something that we
don't understand and we really do need
to take a pause but we don't see that
yet
never mind all the benefits what would
you you don't see what yeah you're
comfortable with all of the potential
ramifications from the current existing
technique I'm sorry we don't see the
reasons to not train a new one for
deploying as I mentioned I think there's
all sorts of risky behavior and there's
limits we put we have to pull things
back sometimes add new ones and then we
don't see something that would stop us
from training the next model uh where
we'd be so worried that we'd create
something dangerous even in that process
let alone the deployment what about you
miss Montgomery
I think we need to use the time to
prioritize ethics and responsible
technology as opposed to posing
development
well wouldn't a pause and development
help the development of protocols for
safety standards and ethics I'm not sure
how practical it is to pause but we
absolutely should be prioritizing safety
protocols okay the the point about
practicality leads me to this I'm
interested in this talk about an agency
and you know maybe that would work
although
having seen how agencies work in this
government they usually get captured by
the interests that they're supposed to
regulate they usually get controlled by
the people who they're supposed to be
watching I mean that's just been our
history for 100 years maybe this agency
would be different I have a little
different idea why don't we just let
people sue you
why don't we just make you liable in
court we knew that we know how to do
that we can pass a statute we can create
a federal right of action that will
allow private individuals who are harmed
by this technology to get into court
and to bring evidence into court
and it can be anybody I mean we want to
talk about crowdsourcing we'll just open
the courthouse doors
will Define a broad right of action
private right of action private citizens
be class actions we'll just open it up
we'll allow people to go into court
we'll allow them present evidence they
say that they were harmed by they were
given medical misinformation they were
given election of misinformation
whatever
why not do that Mr Altman
I mean please forgive my ignorance can't
can't people sue us
well you're not protection by protected
by section 230 but there's not currently
a I don't think a federal right of
action private right of action that says
that if you are harmed by generative AI
technology we will guarantee you the
ability to get into court oh well I
think there's like a lot of other laws
where if you know technology harms you
uh there's standards that we could be
sued under unless I'm really
misunderstanding how things work uh if
the question is are more are clearer
laws about the specifics that this
technology and consumer protection is a
good thing I would say definitely yes
the laws that we have today were
designed long before we had artificial
intelligence and I do not think they
give us enough coverage uh the plan that
you propose I think is a hypothetical
would certainly make a lot of lawyers
wealthy but I think it would be too slow
to affect a lot of the things that we
care about and there are gaps in the law
for example we don't really wait you
think it'd be slower than Congress
yes I do in some ways really well you
know litigation can take a decade or
more oh I think the threat litigation is
a powerful tool I mean how would IBM
like to be successful in no way asking
to take litigation off the table among
the tools but I think for example if I
can uh continue
um we there are areas like copyright
where we don't really have laws we don't
really have a way of thinking about
wholesale misinformation as opposed to
individual pieces of it where say a
foreign actor might make billions of
pieces of misinformation or a local
actor we have some laws around Market
manipulation we could apply but we get
in a lot of situations where we don't
really know which laws apply there would
be loopholes this system is really not
thought through in fact we don't even
know that 230 does or does not apply
here as far as I know I think that
that's something a lot of people
speculated about this afternoon but it's
not something we could fix that well the
question is how
oh easy you just you just it would be
easy for us to say that section 230
doesn't apply to generative AI
um Miss Montgomery a duty of care
which I think fits the idea of a private
right of action now that's exactly right
and also AI is not a shield right so so
if a company discriminates in granting
credit for example or in the hiring
process the by virtue of the fact that
they relied too significantly on an AI
tool they're responsible for that today
regardless of whether they used a tool
or a human to make that decision
I'm going to turn to Senator Booker for
some final questions but I just uh want
to make a quick Point here on the on the
issue of the moratorium
I think we need to be careful The World
Won't Wait
the rest of
the global scientific Community isn't
going to pause we have adversaries that
are moving ahead
and sticking our head in the sand is not
the answer safeguards and protections
yes
but a flat stop sign
sticking our head in the sand
I would be very very worried without
militating for any sort of pause I would
just again emphasize there is a
difference between research which surely
we need to do to keep Pace with our
foreign Rivals and deployment a really
massive scale you know you could deploy
things at a scale of a million people or
10 million people but not 100 million
people or a billion people and if there
are risks you might find them out sooner
and be able to close the barn doors
before the horses leave rather than
after
Senator Booker yeah I I just there will
be no pause I mean there's no
enforcement body to force appall it's
just not not going to happen it's nice
to call for it for any just reasons or
whatsoever but I'm just forgive me for
sounding skeptical nobody's pausing this
thing is crazy
I would agree and I don't think it's a
realistic thing in the world the reason
I personally signed the letter was to
call attention to how serious the
problems were and to emphasize spending
more of our efforts on trustworthy and
safe AI rather than just making a bigger
version of something we already know to
be unreliable yeah so I'm I'm a futurist
I love the exciting about the future and
I guess there's a famous question uh if
you couldn't control for your race your
gender where you land on the planet
Earth or what time in humanity would you
want to be born everyone would say right
now it's the it's still the best time to
be alive because of Technology
Innovation and everything and I'm
excited about what the future holds but
the destructiveness that I've also seen
as a person had seen the transformative
Technologies of uh of of a lot of the
Technologies of the last 25 years is is
what really concerns me and one of the
things especially with companies that
are designed to want to keep my
attention on screens and I'm not just
talking about New Media a 24-hour cable
news is a great example of people that
want to keep your eyes on screens I have
a lot of concerns about the corporate
intention and and Sam this is again why
I find your story so fascinating to me
and your values that I believe in from
our conversations so compelling to me
but but perhaps in that I really want to
just explore what happens when these
companies that are already controlling
so much of our lives a lot has been
written about the Fang companies what
happens when they are the ones that are
dominating this technology as they did
before so Professor Marcus does that
have any concern the role that corporate
power corporate concentration has in
this realm that a few companies might
might control this whole area I
radically changed the shape of my own
life in the last few months and it was
because of what happened with Microsoft
releasing Sydney and it didn't go the
way I thought it would and one way it
did which is I anticipated the
hallucinations I wrote an essay which I
have in the appendix What to Expect When
You're Expecting gpt4 and I said that it
would still be a good tool for
misinformation that it would still have
trouble with physical reasoning
psychological reasoning that it would
hallucinate and then Along Came Sydney
and the initial press reports were quite
favorable and then there was the famous
article by Kevin Roos in which it
recommended he get a divorce and I had
seen Tay and I had seen Galactica from
meta and those had been pulled after
they had problems and Sydney clearly had
problems what I would have done had I
run Microsoft which clearly I do not
would have been to temporarily withdraw
it from the market and they didn't and
that was a wake-up call to me and a
reminder that even if you have a company
like open AI that is a non-profit and
Sam's values I think have come clear
today other people can buy those
companies and do what they like with
them and you know maybe we have a stable
set of actors now but the amount of
power that these systems have to shape
our view use and in our lives is really
really significant and that doesn't even
get into the risks that someone might
repurpose them deliberately for all
kinds of bad purposes and so in the
middle of February I stopped writing
much about technical issues in AI which
is most of what I've written about for
the last decade and said I need to work
on policy this is frightening
and Sam I want to give you an
opportunity it's my sort of last
a question or so
um do you don't you have concerns about
I mean you you I I graduated from
Stanford the I know so many of the
players in the valley uh from VC peel
folks Angel folks to a lot of founders
of companies that we all know do you
have some concern about about a few
players with with extraordinary
resources and power power to influence
Washington I mean I I see us I love I'm
a big believer in the free market but
the reason why I walk into a bodega and
a Twinkie is cheaper than an apple or a
Happy Meal costs less than a bucket of
salad is because of the way the
government tips the scales to pick
winners and losers so the free market is
is is not what it should be when you
have large corporate power that can even
influence the game here do you have some
concerns about that in this in this next
era of technological innovation yeah I
mean again that's that's so much of why
we started openai we have huge concerns
about that uh I think it's important to
democratize the inputs to these systems
the values that we're going to align to
um and I think it's also important to
give people wide use of these tools when
we started the API strategy uh which is
a big part of how we make our systems
available for anyone to use there was a
huge amount of skepticism over that and
it does come with challenges that's for
sure but we think putting this in the
hands of a lot of people and not in the
hands of a few companies uh is really
quite important and we are seeing the
resultant Innovation boom from that
um but but it is absolutely true that
the number of companies that can train
the true Frontier models is going to be
small just because of the resources
required and so I think there needs to
be incredible scrutiny on us and our
competitors uh I think there is a rich
and exciting industry happening of
incredibly good research and new
startups that are not just using our
models but creating their own and I
think it's important to make sure that
whatever regulatory stuff happens
whatever new agencies may or may not
happen we we preserve that fire because
that's critical I'm a big believer in
the democratizing potential of
Technology but I've seen the promise of
that fail time and time again uh where
people say oh this is going to have a
big democratizing force my team works on
a lot of issues about the reinforcing of
of bias through algorithms the failure
to advertise certain opportunities in
certain zip codes
um but you seem to be saying and I heard
this with web3 that this is going to be
die fide uh decentralized Finance all
these things are going to happen
but this is not this seems to me not
even to offer that promise because the
people who are designing these it takes
so much power energy resources are you
saying that this that my dreams of
Technology further democratizing
opportunity and more
um are are possible within a technology
that is ultimately I think going to be
very centralized to a few players who
already control so much
so
this point that I made about use of use
of the model and building on top of it
as a this is really a new platform right
it is definitely important to talk about
who's going to create the models I want
to do that I also think it's really
important to decide to whose values
we're going to align these models but in
terms of using the models the people
that build on top of the open AI API do
incredible things and it's you know
people frequently comment like I can't
believe you get this much technology for
this little money and so what people are
the companies people are building
putting AI everywhere using our API
which does let us put safeguards in
place uh I think that's quite exciting
and I think that is how it is being
democracy not not how it's going to be
but how it is being democratized right
now there is a whole new Cambrian
explosion of new businesses new products
new Services happening buy lots of
different companies on top of these
models so I'll say chairman as I close
that
I have most Industries resist even
reasonable regulation from seat belt
laws uh to we've been talking a lot
recently about rail safety that the only
way we're going to see the
democratization of values I think and
while there are noble companies out
there is if we create rules of the road
that enforce certain safety measures
like we've seen with other technology
thank you
thanks Senator Booker uh and I I
couldn't agree more that
um in terms of consumer protection which
I've been doing for a while
participation by the industry is
tremendously important and not just
rhetorically but in real terms because
we have a lot of industries that come
before us and say oh we're all in favor
of rules but not those rules those rules
we don't like
and it's every rule in fact that they
don't like and I sense that there is a
willingness to participate here that is
genuine and authentic I thought about uh
asking chat GPT to
do a new version of don't stop thinking
about tomorrow
because that's what we need to be doing
here and as Senator Hawley has pointed
out Congress doesn't always move at the
pace of technology and that may be a
reason why we need a new agency but we
also need to recognize the world the
rest of the world is going to be moving
as well and you've been enormously
helpful in focusing us and Illuminating
some of these questions and performed a
great service by being here today so
thank you to everyone of our
Witnesses and uh
I'm going to close the hearing leave the
record open for one week in case anyone
wants to submit anything I encourage any
of you who have either manuscripts that
are going to be published or
observations uh from your companies uh
to to submit them to us and we look
forward to our next hearing this one is
closed